THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION WILL TO OR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS IN REPRESENTS
TO THE KOBE NINETEEN M. AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. AND WE MUST
LIVE NOT AS A GATHER AND HE TO
SO DISTANCE AND COVERING. IN
COMPLIANCE THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE MADE ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL. IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT
EVERY COMMITTEE MEMBER IS
EXPECTED TO BE IN PERSON HERE
TODAY. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANTS TOTAL
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
ACCESS CODE. EIGHT TWO EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT TWO. HE TOLD AND ON
HOW TO TALK. TO WORKS REFER TO
THIS AND OR COMMIT WEBSITE. FOR
MORE INFORMATION. WHEN WE MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO SIGN UP LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN THIS I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THE MAYBE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL. INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE'VE GOT
A HUGE HEARING TODAY MEMBERS
AND WE NEED TO FINISH BY NOON
IF WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN THAT
WOULD BE GREA SO WE CAN
PREPARE THE CHAMBERS TO BE
CLEANED AND PREPARED FOR THE
AFTERNOON HEARING. TO
FACILITATE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE. TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR WITNESS PRESENTATIONS
EACH SIDE WILL BE GIVEN UP TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES. PLEASE DON'T
FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO USE ALL
FIFTEEN MINUTES. WE WILL KEEP
TIME AFTER THAT WE'LL TAKE
WHATEVER NECESSARY TIME. FOR
MEMBERS TO DISCUSS THE BILLS.
NOW LET'S GET STARTED WITH THE
BUSINESS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR.
BY ESTABLISHING A QUORUM.
MISTER CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IN MEMBERS JUST A
REMINDER PLEASE TO BE SURE THAT
YOUR MIKE IS TURNED ON THE
SPEAK INTO THE MIKE. CONSULTS
ADULT HERE BATES HERE BATES
HERE ALLEN THIS ONE PARTULA
HERE MARCH LETTER HERE BAKER.
BAKER HERE CORTESE- CORTESE
HERE DAHLE. DOT. MCGUIRE
THEY'RE REQUIRED HELLO THIS
YEAR BELINDA'S HERE MAN HERE
MEN HERE NEWMAN HERE NEWMAN
HERE. RUBIO SKINNER HERE
SKINNER HERE NUMBER BY CASTING
HERE MY COUNTY HERE WELL
PRESIDENT WILL PRESENT
FOLLOWING YOUR. DALY THANK YOU
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU MISTER
A CONSULTANT OF THE A QUORUM SO
WE'LL TAKE A THE CONSENT
CALENDAR QUICKLY THAT THESE ARE
THE BILLS ON SB SIX SIX AS
PEACE NINE FIVE SO SIX TWENTY
NINE EIGHT FOR TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT-
SENATORS SB TWO THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE WAS PREVIOUSLY
ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR BUT THE
COMMITTEE RECEIVED OPPOSITION
ON MONDAY. THAT HAS BEEN
REMOVED AND WE'LL HEAR IT TODAY
DOES ANYONE HAVE AN OBJECTION
TO ANY BILL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THIS TIME. HEARING
NONE IS OUR MOTION THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OCEAN CENTER ARCHULETA
THANK YOU- NOW THE FIRST PART
WILL BE S. C. R. TWENTY SIX.
AND S. C. R. TWENTY SEVEN WILL
HAVE TO BRING IT UP IN TWO
PARTS. CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
TWO HIGHWAY NAMING RESOLUTIONS
S. C. R. TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GONZALEZ HERE YES FIVE
DOLLARS FIVE. BATES HI BATES I.
ALLEN. YEAH PARTULA HI MARCH
LETTER HI BAKER HI HI CORTESE.
CORTE HI DAHLE HI KELLY I DOT
THAT'S WHERE RIGHT HI MELENDEZ
ALLEN I MAN ALL RIGHT MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN I RUBIO.
SKINNER I. HI SKINNER HI NUMBER
TO LIKE ASKING WHY CASKEY I
WILL BUY WILL. IF. THIRTEEN
OKAY YOU WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
FOR ABSENT ON PART OF THE K.
OTHER IN ALL THE REMAINING I ON
THE CAN CALENDAR CONSISTS OF S.
B. SIXTY SEVEN NINE FIVE SO SIX
NINE FOURTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHT.
CONSULTANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. REPUBLICAN CENTEL GOOD.
HI HI BATES HI BATES HELLO.
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA BAKER AND
I PUT I PATAGIA THE ONLY. DAHLE
FIVE DOT. MCGUIRE WHERE I
BELINDA'S BELINDA'S MIN AYE MIN
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO
SKINNER. SKINNER HI NUMBER.
WHAT WHITE HOUSEKEEPING CAL I
WILL HI WILK HI. THIRTEEN OKAY
CAN TO PART THIRTEEN THE ROLE
OPEN AS WELL OKAY MEMBERS ARE
GONNA GO AND START- LITTLE BIT
OUT OF OR- WILL START FOR WITH
SENATOR LEE I KNOW SHE'S BEEN
WAITING. WELCOME SENATOR LEYVA
YOU'RE READY TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL. ON S. THREE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER CHAIR
MORNING GOOD MEMBER. THANK YOU
FOR THE ARE. TO MY BILL TO. SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO ESTABLISH THE
ME AND THE HEAVY DO ZERO IMAGE
BE FLEET. A SUS PER THAT IS A
MOUTHFUL. WHICH WILL BE A- AT
THE CAL AIR RESOURCE BOARD AND
BY THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION
CONTROL FINANCING AUTHORITY.
THIS PROGRAM WILL IN
CONSULTATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
DESIGN NEW FINANCING TOOLS TO
HELP OWNERS OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES PURCHASE CLEANER
ZERO EMISSION ALTERNATIVES. AS
MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS BUSES AND
BUSES ARE A MAJOR SOURCE OF AIR
POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTING TO POOR AIR
QUALITY AND NEGATIVE
RESPIRATORY HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THESE LOCAL AIR MISSIONS HURT
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
POPULATIONS. REPLACING THESE
VEHICLES WITH ZERO EMISSION
ALTERNATIVES IS NEEDED TO
REDUCE THE HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WORSENS CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT SOLUTION
FOR FINANCING THE TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES HAS BEEN
BELCHER OR GRANT PROGRAMS IN
ORDER TO MEET THE DIVERSE
FINANCIAL NEEDS OF CURRENT AND
FUTURE FLEET OWNERS IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE PUTS
MORE TOOLS. IN THE TOOLBOX
TRANSITIONING FLEETS SHOULD BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND EQUITABLE
BOTH FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVE IN THE AREAS WITH HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF DIESEL
POLLUTION FOR THE BUSINESS
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO MANAGES
THESE VEHICLES. THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS TO GET THE STATE
TO THINK CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW
WE CAN BEST LEVERAGE. BRING A
PRICE CAPITAL INSTANCE WHERE
MAKES. AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MAXIMIZE THE
ABILITY FOR FLEETS OF ALL SIZES
TO TRANSITION TO SERVE AS A
MISSION OPTIONS. SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO WILL CREATE A ONE
STOP SHOP WEBSITE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL THE PUT
POTENTIAL FINANCING. GRANT
OPTIONS AND OTHER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
HELP THE TEAM FINANCING OF
THESE VEHICLES WE KNOW THAT
TRANSITIONING TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IS A KEY COMPONENT. TO
ENSURING BETTER HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AS WE HAVE A AS
WE WELL HAVING ROBUST SECRETIVE
FINANCING TOOLS THAT WILL HELP
TO ACCELERATE OUR ABILITY TO
GET CLEANER AND GREENER TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD. WITH ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AS MICHAEL COLEMAN
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FOR DEFENCE FUND AND BILL
MCGOVERN WITH COALITION CLEAN
AIR AT THE PROPER TIME MEMBERS
ELSE FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA AND MODERATOR-
THE FIRST WITNESS AND SUPPORT
IS MISTER. MICHAEL KOK HOLDEN.
YES HI GOOD MORNING HEAR ME.
YES WE- THANK YOU COULD MY IS
MIKE COLE LOOKING VERY TO FUND
AND WE ARE THE PROUD SPONSORS
SENATE BILL THREE SEVEN TO
CLEANER AND GREENER CROP. THE
MEDIA AND HEAVY DUTY YEAH MARK.
WHICH INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM
SEMI TRUCK AND DELIVER VANS THE
CITY BY AND GARBAGE. IT
ENTRANCE SAID OMISSION.
CONDITION WILL HAVE BEEN
OUTSIDE. ON A POLLS WRONG POP.
ESPECIALLY WHEN CONSIDERING
LOCAL POLLUTION IN THE CITY TO
HELP IMPROVE. CALIFORNIA CANNOT
CHANGE THIS JUST USING ALL THE
FUNDS. IT'S KIND OF IN I THINK
TO GENERATE LOTS. SENATE BILL
THREE SEVEN TWO EIGHT THREE
KEEP. FIRST IT DEPLOYED PUBLIC
FUNDS HIS NEED NOTE HOW TO PUT
COUNTRY TRADING FIVE OF THE
FUNDS THE TO ARE VULNERABLE.
THE SECOND IT ENABLED INTO. IN
FIVE UP FOR ALL PLEASE. SPIDER
THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CAN
FINAL AT THE- TO UTILIZE EXIST
RELATIONSHIP WITH PRICE
FINANCING AND WE THE TALKING
INDUSTRY. ETFC SEE PC AT THE
CRITICAL IMPLEMENT PARTNER
ALONG WITH THEIR RECORD BOARD.
AND ARGUS FULL SET OF RELEVANT
TO RELEVANT TO THE FLEET.
HAVING THE AIR AS HE AGENTS
WILL ENABLE THE INTERAGENCY
COURTNEY INCLUDES QUITTING THE
DEVELOPMENT THE ONE SHOP BY.
GENERATE SENATE BILL THREE HAVE
TWO DELIVER. SOCIETAL AND
ECONOMIC. INCLUDING IMPROVED
PUBLIC HEALTH PRODUCED I NEED.
LARA LIFECYCLE FOR UP IN THE-
INCLUDE I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT
LEYVA AND HER STOCK A CLEAR
ENTIRELY- IT OR SHUT. MAIN
CREATURE I THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER COLVIN NOW MR
MODERATOR SWITCH TO MISTER
BUILD. MODERATOR TO WE HAVE
MISTER MCGOVERN ON THE LINE. I
DID NOT SEE MR MCGOVERN IN THE
LIST IS MISTER MCGOVERN IF YOU
ARE IN AS A PARTICIPANT PLEASE
PRESS STAR THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OKAY IF HE'S NOT ON THE
LINE WILL GO AHEAD AND PROCEED
WITH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE
DO HAVE HIM JUST JOINED OKAY
GREAT. THANKS VERY MUCH MANAGER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WAS ON
HOLD FOR SEVERAL MINUTES BUT
THIS IS BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR- IN
STRONG SUPPORTER SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS ON THE VERGE
OF A TRANSFORMATIONAL CLEAN UP-
ARE TRUCKING SECTOR. AND WE CAN
HAVE GOODS MOVEMENT WITHOUT
INFLICTING OPTIC DIESEL
EXHAUST. ON OUR COMMUNITY. AND
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A
COMBINATION OF STRONG
REGULATIONS WHICH ARE PROBABLY
HERE AND PROBABLY ON THE WAY.
AND ALSO INCENTIVES AND
CREATIVE FINANCING TO MAKE SURE
THAT TRUCK OWNERS CAN PURCHASE
THE NEW CLEANER TRUCKS. EACH
TRUCKS WILL ACTUALLY HAVE A
LOWER TOTAL COST OF OWNERSHIP
THAN CONVENTIONAL DIESEL FUEL
TRUCKS BUT THE INITIAL STICKER
PRICE. IS HIGHER FOR THE ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY. WE
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE
BILL'S INCLUSION OF A 75% FOR
OUR MOST UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE THE MOST BURDENS
CURRENTLY BY TRUCKING POLLUTION.
FINALIZATION OF COURT TRUCKS
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A CLUSTER OF
TRUCKING AND A- HIGH BURDEN OF
POLLUTION IN THOSE PORT SIDE
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO THE
PRIORITIZATION OF SMALL WEEDS
WHICH ARE THOSE WHICH ARE MOST
IN NEED. OF THE FINANCING HELLO
SO- WITH THAT WE THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR THE
BILL AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL
APPROVE IT THIS MORNING THANK
YOU. IF YOU MISTER MCGOVERN
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND GO ON TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT LET'S BEGIN OF ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
IN SUPPORT. OF SB THREE SEVENTY
TWO. OKAY THERE ARE NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEN NONE- MODERATOR
WILL GO BACK TO THE LINE FOR
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS OF MY BETTER LUCK WITH
THE WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA THE COURT.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHOPPING CLAY
ABOUT THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHARED MEMBERS
VINCENT FOR A MUCH OF WHAT THE
CLIENT CENTERED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MELISSA ROMERO WITH.
IN SUPPORT. I'M SORRY COULD YOU
PLEASE REPEAT YOUR PHONE CUT
OUT. MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA WE GET CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHULKIN
MEN WITH THE LOS ANGELES
CLEANTECH INCUBATOR AND PARK.
MY THIRTYSEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING WILL GUARANTEE MERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. MINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BEN
KELLER I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN A
GALLAGHER WAS THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS STEVEN
ROSENBAUM WITH THREE FIFTY
JORDAN VALLEY- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ONE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS BILL MURPHY
WITH ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION NOR
COUNSEL CAL CHAPTERS AND THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
NINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DANIEL HAHN WITH THE
ORGANIZATION GREAT ALTERNATIVES
GREATER LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MODERATOR OKAY THAT
CONCLUDES OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES LEAD WITNESSES ON
FILE IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
WHICH IS GREAT BUT WILL GO HEAD
AND LOOK TO THE GALLERY IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY ONE
TWELVE. THERE ARE NONE OKAY
MODERATOR WILL GO BACK TO THE
LINE TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. HE WAS
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB THREE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GET TO THE LINE
NUMBER.
ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY FIVE
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM Q. WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS IN OPOSITION
OF SB THREE SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU MODERATOR OKAY WE'RE GONNA
GO BRING THIS BACK DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FIVE
PROPRIA TIME I WILL MOVE THE
BILL I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. AS
ALSO A- SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS
A PORT AND A GOODS MOVEMENT
CORRIDOR. AND KNOWING THE
IMPACT THAT THE DIESEL EXHAUST
POLLUTION HAS HAD. ON A NUMBER
OF MY- LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
THIS IS REALLY NEEDED BECAUSE
AS UNFORTUNATELY MORE AND MORE
TRACKING IS MOVED TO
INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS. THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO. TO
GET THE EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD
PROTECT ALL OF US INCLUDING
THEMSELVES SO THIS IS REALLY
NEEDED BILL REALLY APPRECIATE
THE- SENATOR BRING IT FORWARD.
AND VERY VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AND AS I INDICATED I
WILLMOVE IT WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR MCCASKEY YEAH THANK YOU
MA'AM. TWITTER I. ONCE AGAIN I
FEEL LIKE A BROKEN RECORD. LIKE
TO REPEAT THE COMMITTEE INTO
FOLKS THAT. ONE DIESEL TRUCK
REMOVED ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS THE SAME CLIMATE AFFECTED
SAID AS A DIESEL TRUCK REMOVED
IN A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
THEY'VE FROM A CLIMATE POINT OF
VIEW AND CARBON IT'S THE SAME.
FROM THE MISSIONS AND-
POLLUTION PROBLEM- I GET THE
BIT I'M FOCUSING IN ON. ONE
APPLAUD THE- CAPITAL
INSTRUMENTS IN THE- COSTS
MOVING INSTRUMENTS AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNMENT BACK PERFORMANCE
GUARANTEES ON THAT RISK
MANAGEMENT HAS ELEMENTS THAT
WILL ACTUALLY GET FOLKS IN. I'M
FOCUSING ON SORT OF. THE WOODEN
ELEMENT OF HAVING 75% OF THE
FINANCING PRODUCTS FOR THESE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY MISSIONS
WHICH WERE STILL OUT MAKING
ARE. LIKE TO BELIEVE MISSIONS
BUT IS THAT I. I GUESS THE
QUESTION TO THE AUTHORS SAID.
HERE WE- A TRUCKER WHO HAS FOR.
SHE DELIVERS FISH TO THE FOR
CLIENTS. RIGHT NOW EVERY EVERY
SHOP HAS 25% SO THREE OF THEM
ARE LOCATED BY THE PORT AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY'S
DISTRICT ONE OF THEM IS LOCATED
OUTSIDE THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. PEOPLE START EATING
MORE FISH OUTSIDE THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AND
THAT NUMBER BECOME 73% OR 71%
OR WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS BUT
IT DOESN'T. FIT THIS WOODEN.
FIGURE FOR FINANCING PRODUCTS
EVEN THOUGH WITH MAKE A-
OBSERVATION THAT OBVIOUSLY MOST
OF THESE AREAS AFFECTED BY THE
POLLUTION THE DIESEL POLLUTION
OR THE CARBON IS AT. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THE 75% BECAUSE THE
FIRST TIME I'VE SEEN THIS AND
THINGS AND WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
MY FISH TRUCKER THAT IS NOW NO
LONGER WANTS TO DO THE PROGRAM
BUT CAN'T CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN
THESE FINANCIAL- OPPORTUNITIES
WILL BE AVAILABLE THE QUESTION
IS WHY 75% YEAH. WOULD YOU LIKE
IT TO BE A 100% 50% WHAT IS
YOUR NUMBER NO I WHICH I WOULD
SAY IT AGAIN YOU YOU WANT TO WE
CAN CONVERT THE LIGHT DUTY
TRUCKS SO WE'RE GOING INTO THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS WE
WANT TO MAKE THESE. THESE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY WHO'S
WHO IT NEEDS TO FINANCING I
THINK THESE ARE ALL GOOD
FINANCIAL TOOLS BUT WE GET A
CUT OUT PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
50% THEIR BUSINESS IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY 455% OR
WHATEVER THE NUMBER THAT THAT
THEY- THEY WANT TO. JUMP IN ON
THIS THE BILL ABILITY UP
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT
THE BANKS HAVE ALREADY TOLD
THEM YOU'RE NOT. YOU'RE NOT.
YOU FINANCE NOT ELIGIBLE THEY
HAVE NO PLACE TO GO IF THEY
DON'T MEET THE 75% THRESHOLD I
GET. I GET THE PUBLIC POLICY
GOAL BUT IT'S- IT'S WOODEN AND
IT DOESN'T ALLOW. FOR FIFTY ONE
FOR SIXTY TWO OR SIXTY EIGHT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WE WOULD
SAY CLEARLY THIS PERSON IS
SERVING AND- OPERATES IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY BUT-
THAT. THRESHOLD FOR THESE
FINANCIAL TOOLS IS SO HARD AND
THEY CAN'T EVEN GROW THEIR
BUSINESS. OUTSIDE THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THEY WOULD GET KNOCKED OUT SO
THAT'S- I'M NOT. I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR THE BILL I'M JUST. SO
CENTER RIGHT HEALTHCARE I WOULD
SAY THAT THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
THIS HAS NOT BEEN TRIED BEFORE
NO ONE HAS DONE THIS BEFORE WE
RECOGNIZE. THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM YOU'VE GOT THE AMAZONS
OF THE WORLD. WHO EVERYBODY
THINKS IS SO AMAZING BECAUSE
THEY ARE ABLE TO HAVE A ZERO
EMISSION. VEHICLES BUT THAT'S
JUST BECAUSE THEY HAVE MORE
MONEY THAN GOD. SO THIS IS A
WAY FOR US TO TRY AND HELP THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY. HEAVY DUTY
SIZE TRUCKS IF THIS PROGRAM
WORKS THE IC IS EXPANDING THAT.
AND YOUR PERSON SELLING THE
FISH WE HOPE SHE CAN GET 275%
BUT IF NOT IN THE FUTURE. WE
CANNOT WE CAN EITHER DO ANOTHER
BILL THIS IS THE FIRST FORAY
INTO THIS AREA. A LOT OF ALWAYS
DEPENDS ON THE FISH EATING
PUBLIC THAT IS CORRECT. THANK
YOU SENATOR. AKOWSKI SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I ALSO WANT TO COMMEND
AUTHOR- PAID UNDER. I GUESS
WHAT MISTER WHITE HOUSE USED TO
SAY BUT AS THE OTHER STATED
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP I JUST
REALLY DO APPRECIATE. THE
CREATIVE FINANCING AND JUST
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX I
THINK THIS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. BECAUSE
AND RUBIO WOULD BE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
US SENATOR NEWMAN AND THEN
WE'LL GO T SEND IT BACK. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- CENTER AYE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT MAIL.
DISTRICT AFICIONADOS- I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR. DID SHE AND
I AND OTHERS IN THIS ROOM
REPRESENT AREAS THAT ARE
HEAVILY IMPACT BY FREIGHT.
TRAFFIC AND CONGESTION. AND
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
PARTICULARLY AS THE SHIPPING
AND WAREHOUSING INDUSTRIES
UNDERGO A REVOLUTION- AND A
FUNDAMENTAL PARADIGM SHIFT. AND
THEY ARE CURRENTLY IN THE MIDST
OF BUILDING WELL OVER A MILLION
SQUARE FEET OF WAREHOUSING
SPACE. IN COMMUNITIES THAT WILL
SOON BE IMPACTED SO. I DO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR I THINK THIS
IS A VERY VERY SMART. EMILY
SENSIBLE FIRST STEP ON ON A
MOVING THIS TECHNOLOGY INTO
COMMUNITIES. AND CHANNELS WHERE
IT'S NEEDED I WOULD ASK TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU WE'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN SENATOR BAKER. I DIAZ
SAYS WHEN AND YEAH THE FOR
AGAINST CHANGE TO HAPPEN LEVELS
AND- MEDIA AND HEAVY DO. FLEETS
IS ESSENTIAL IN. A ALSO THE
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE. ASPECTS OF
THIS HOW IT WILL HELP CLEAN UP
THE NEIGHBORHOOD SO AGAIN I
COMMEND THE AUTHOR AS WELL. I'M
GLAD WE'RE TACKLING THE SECTORS.
THANK YOU CENTER BAKER THANK
YOU I THINK I SEE NO OTHER
MIKES- I'M SORRY SENATOR MEN. I
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO- I
THINK AT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL IT'S A
THOUGHTFUL BILL- IF WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO REDUCE. CARBON
EMISSIONS. TRANSPORTATION
PRETTY GOOD WITH THESE MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY. VEHICLES IS GOT
TO BE A PLACE WHERE WE START.
AND I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
DEAL BECAUSE YOU KNOW TOO OFTEN
WHEN WE THINK OF. REGULATORY
POLICIES IN THIS AREA WE'RE
LOOKING AT STICKS AND WE IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT WE HAVE CARROTS
TO GO WITH THAT- TO HELP.
FACILITATE THE ABILITY OF
ACTORS TO MEET THESE. AMBITIOUS
GOALS THAT WE'RE SETTING IN
CALIFORNIA SO I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR AND WOOD. ALSO TO BE A
CO AUTHOR AT THE EARLIEST
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
CENTERMAN WITHOUT HAVING TO.
GRAY A SCENE OTHER. UP I DON'T
BELIEVE SO OKAY I WILL ALSO
MENTION THAT. I BELIEVE THERE
ABOUT SEVEN FIFTEEN OR SO STATE
PROGRAMS THAT. ARE DIRECTED
TOWARDS MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY. THIS
WOULD ALSO BE ONE WAY TO HELP
NAVIGATE. ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS
AND SORT OF DEMYSTIFY A LOT OF
THE STUFF. I WANT ALSO TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL TO GREAT BILL.
SENATOR LEAVE AND YOU'VE GOT A
LOT OF CO AUTHORS NOW SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THE CENTRE
GONZALEZ YES I APPRECIATE ALL
THE COMMENTS AND THE QUESTIONS
AND THANK YOU TO OUR NEW CO
AUTHORS. MEMBERS WHEN I WAS
ELECTED TO THE SENATE I DID NOT
KNOW WHAT IT UNFUNDED MANDATE
WAS. I QUICKLY LEARNED WHAT
THAT WAS SO I HAVE TRIED MOVING
FORWARD TO ALWAYS TO CREATE
LEGISLATION. THAT FOR ASKING
SOMEONE TO DO SOMETHING WE
PROVIDE THE MONEY AS WELL. THIS
IS JUST GOING TO BE ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE STATE'S TOOLBOX
WHEN IT COMES TO TRANSITIONING
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. WE
NOTE THAT IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
BUT WE CAN'T ALWAYS JUST PUT
THE BURDEN ON THE TRUCK OWNERS.
SO THIS IS A WAY TO HELP THEM
AND AS THE CHAIR- WISELY SAID
THIS IS A WAY TO BRING
EVERYTHING TOGETHER AND MAKE IT
A ONE STOP SHOP FOR THESE
TRUCKERS. SO MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO. SENATOR RUBIO
MOTIONSTHANK YOU- THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTHER. AND SHE CONSULTANT IF
YOU CAN READ THE MOTION. AND
THE CALL ROLLED. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SKEWS ME THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GONZALEZ HI THE DALLAS I BATES
HI BATES AYE ALLEN. PACKAGES
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE BUT TOO
LITTLE I EXPECTED. BETTER HI
CORTE ALL RIGHT CORTESE DOLLY.
DOT HI DOT I MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
AYE BELINDA'S AYE MELINDA'S AYE
MAN AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER
ACT NUMBER I LIKE HUSKY HI BY
KELSEY I WILL HI WILK I.
FOURTEEN ZERO OKAY BELIEVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THINKING MEMBERS. THANK YOU
OKAY WE GOT TEN MORE BILLS NEXT
SENATOR MCGUIRE ARE YOU READY
TO PRESENT ON YOUR BILL S. B.
TWO THIRTY ONE. HE IS GREAT. HI
RIGHT. YEAH. UHHUH.
ALL RIGHT
WELCOME SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH READING CHAIR IN
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT I'LL BE QUICK HERE'S
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO SB TWO
THIRTY ONE THAT WILL ALLOW
CALTRANS TO TRANSFER THE BLUES
BEACH PROPERTY FOR CHADBOURNE
GULCH BEACH WHICH THEY OWN BUT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO TRANSFER
TO A NONPROFIT ORIGIN AGENCY
ORGANIZED BY THE ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES SURE WOULD VALLEY
BAND OF POMO INDIANS AND THE
CAO ET KILEY VALENTINA
POMERANIANS. THIS PROPERTY IS
LOCATED OUT ON THE GORGEOUS BUT
VERY REMOTE MENDOCINO COAST AT
THE BLUES EACH PROPERTY HAS
TYPICALLY BEEN A VERY POPULAR
SPOT THAT CATERS TO BOTH LOCALS
AND TOURISTS ALIKE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO ACRES
OF LAND STRETCHING ALONG
HIGHWAY ONE IT SLIGHTLY HILLY
IT'S MADE UP OF TWELVE TOTAL
PARCELS OF VARIOUS SHAPES AND
SIZES IT RUNS ALL THE WY DOWN
TO THE BEACH AND OVER THE YEARS
THERE HAVE BEEN CANDIDLY SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
FOR THE LOCAL COMMUNITY ILLEGAL
CAMPAIGNS CARS GETTING STUCK ON
THE BEACH AND IN A BIND INTO
TRASH. SO HOW DID WE GET TO
THIS BILL BACK IN FEBRUARY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IT SURE WOULD
VALLEY BAND OF POMO INDIANS
AROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES IN
COUNTY VALLEY BAND OF POMO
INDIANS FORMED A FORMAL WORKING
GROUP WITH US TO ADVOCATE FOR A
JOINT OWNERSHIP OF THE PROPERTY
THE REASON THE THREE TRIBES
WITH A HISTORICAL STEWARDS AT
THAT VERY SACRED PIECE OF LAND
THE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO ACRES
AT A AS THE CURRENT OWNER OF
THE BLUES BEACH PROPERTY
CALTRANS ACQUIRED MOST OF THESE
TWELVE PARCELS THROUGH THE
FEDERAL SCENIC EASEMENT
PROGRAM. DECADES AGO CALTRANS
DOESN'T HAVE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO TRANSFER LAND TO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS CURRENTLY
DESPITE THESE GOVERNMENTS BEING
RECOGNIZED AS SOVEREIGN NATIONS
UNDER STATE LAW NOW CALTRANS
DOES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
TRANSFER LAND IN MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENTS AND. NONPROFITS
HENCE THIS IS A WHY WE ARE IN
FRONT OF YOUR TEAM CAN MANAGER.
TO BE ABLE TO TRANSFER TO THIS
TRIBAL AND- THE SHERMAN VALLEY
BROWN VALLEY IN COUNTY DALY
TRIES WILL NOT ONLY CARE FOR
THE LAND. BUT ALSO HOST
IMPORTANT HISTORICAL PROGRAMS
INCLUDING EDUCATIONAL CULTURAL
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS TRISH
TRADITIONAL NET FISHING IN SEA
WEED HARVESTING IN TERMINAL
CEREMONIAL ACTIVITIES. OUT
MANAGER WANNA BE SUPER CLEAR
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. THIS PLAN
WILL BE SOLELY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CULTURAL
PROTECTION. THERE WOULD NOT BE
A DEVELOPMENTS SUCH AS A CASINO
OR HOTELS OR ANY OTHER
COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY IN FACT WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THIS BILL. TO MAKE IT
EXPLICIT. WITHIN THE LANGUAGE.
PUBLIC BEACH ACCESS IT MUST
ALSO BE MAINTAINED IT'S
OUTLINED IN THE BILL. IN THERE
MAY BE SOME CLOSURE CLOSURE OF
THE LAND CLOSER TO THE HIGHWAY
NOT THE BEACH BUT CLOSER TO
HIGHWAY TO PROTECT SOME
CULTURAL RESOURCES. HOURS FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS WILL BE SUNRISE
TO SUNSET. I N. NOW MANAGER
WEARY STAB MACHINE AKKAR HAD TO
HOP COMMUNITY COMMITTEE THROUGH
THE WESTPORT ADVISORY MUNICIPAL
ADVISORY COUNCIL- TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH BOTH THE TRIBES OUR
OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITY. AS THIS BILL. MOVES
FORWARD RETURNING THIS LAND THE
TRIBES IS NOT ONLY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO BUT TO ALSO LEAD TO
THE PROPER STEWARDSHIP IN
HISTORICAL PRESERVATION. AND
HAVING AN ACTIVE LANE MANAGER
BEING VERY CANDID OUT IN THIS
REMOTE STRETCH OF GORGEOUS
BEACH THAT WILL BE A BENEFIT TO
ALL THIS. HONORED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
WITH ME IT'S GONNA BE THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE SURE WOULD
VALLEY BAND OF POMO INDIANS.
WOULD ACTIVATE A WELCOME
CHAIRMAN AFTERNOON TO THE
COMMITTEE- AT THE PROPER TIME
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE MANAGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE BRING ON IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO THIRTY ONE-
CHAIRWOMAN ROBIN ON. LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU FOR THAT
INTRODUCTION- I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT BLUES EACH- HOPE PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE TO SHORE VALLEY
ALLEN COUNTY BOTH TRIED. WE'VE
LIVED IN THAT AREA BERMAN
pLINNEA ALL THREE TRIED THE
DIRECT DESCENDANTS OF THE
NORTHERN POMO AND COAST YOU SEE
PEOPLE WHO LIVED IN STARTED
WITH DIFFICULT TO REACH AREA.
ARE EVER. THE THREE TRIBES WITH
A COMBINED MEMBERSHIP OF OVER
FOUR THOUSAND BELIEVE THAT THE
POLICE EACH PROPERTY IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR CULTURAL
AND HISTORY THE TRIFLE EVEN THE
SACREDNESS OF THE AREA AND
CONTINUAL USE OF ITS RESOURCES.
AS YOU WERE TO THE LAND WE FEEL
WE ARE BEST SUITED TO PROTECT
AND PRESERVE THE PROPERTY OUR
ANCESTORS ONCE INHABITED. IN
THE NEAR FUTURE WE HOPE TO
UTILIZE PARTS OF THE PROPERTY
FOR CEREMONIAL AND EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES. I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR REQUIRED FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND WE ASK FOR I
WROTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIRWOMAN WE APPRECIATE THAT-
THE MODERATOR BUT- I DON'T
THINK THERE ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTING THAT'S
ONLY ONE OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
REQUIRE SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY ANYONE
IN SUPPORT. YOU SEE NON ROOM
ONE TWELVE. C. NONE SO WE'LL GO
BACK TO YOUR MODERATOR FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THE GENERAL AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTED QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR. OKAY WE'LL
NEXT GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WE DID RECEIVE LATE
OPPOSITION BUT NO FORMAL-
OPPOSITION REGISTERED- CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
ANYONE IN. THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
TWO THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THIRTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR I DON'T SEE ANY
COMMENTS OR ANYONE IN- THE
GALLERY OR RENT ROOM ONE TWELVE
IN OPPOSITION EITHER OKAY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS
FOR DISCUSSION I BELIEVE
SENATOR RUBIO DO YOU HAVE YOUR
MAKE UP. SENATOR RUBIO. DO YOU
HAVE YOUR MAKE UP PROBABLY NOT
OKAY SO NO OTHER OKAY KNOW
WHETHER A MEMBERS. MIKE'S UP
SENATOR MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE TO%
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
VOTING. MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
SB TWO THIRTY ONE. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE DALLAS HI DOLLARS AYE BATES
HI BATES HI ELLEN HI ELLEN HI
BUDGET LETTER I WHICH LITTLE
HIGH BAKER HI. HI CORTESE I DOLLY. DOLLY I
THOUGHT HI DON HI MCGUIRE. I
THINK THA I MCGUIRE HI
BELINDA'S. MELENDEZ AYE MIN.
FIVE MILLION HI NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER FIVE SKINNER I NUMBER
FIVE NUMBER I LIKE HOUSEKEEPING
HI MICHALSKI I WILL. SIXTEEN
RIGHT SIXTEEN LEAVE THE CALL
OPEN. NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR
PORTANTINO. RIGHT WELCOME
SENATOR PORTANTINO TO PRESENT
ON SB. THREE EIGHTY ONE. YEAH
THAT'S FINE. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB THREE A THREE EIGHTY
ONE THE BILL WHICH MAKES
CHANGES IN THE DISPOSITION
PROCESS OF THE S. R. SEVEN TEN
HOMES OWNED BY CALTRANS FIRST
I'D LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
YOUR STAFF WORK DILIGENTLY
WITH- MY STAFF SO THANK YOU FOR
THE- SPIRIT OF COOPERATION IN
THE HARD WORK. SB THREE ONE
LOOKS TO MAKE IT ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE FOR THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA TO PURCHASES OF
SUBSTANTIALLY REHABILITATE
MAINTAIN AND ADMINISTER IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS
WHICH WILL HELP TO ADDRESS
LOCAL HOUSING CRISIS. IT IS
ALSO BEEN DETERMINED THAT THE
SR SEVEN TEN FREEWAY GAP
BETWEEN- HAMMERED PASADENA CAN
NO LONGER BE BUILT OBVIOUSLY SO
SOUTH PASADENA HAS EXPRESSED
THE NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES TO THE CURRENT SALES
PROCESS THESE CHANGES WILL
ALLOW FOR MORE DIRECT
INTERVENTION BY CITIES IN
PURCHASING THE PROPERTIES IT
WILL GIVE TENANTS. A SINGLE
FAMILY AND MULTI FAMILY UNITS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE AND
GIVES CALTRANS. A NINE MONTH
TIME LINE TO SELL. WELL ARE NOT
OTHER OFFER ON A- PROPERTIES TO
THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA AT
ACQUISITION PRICE. WITH A FIFTY
FIVE YEAR COVENANT ON THE LAND
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABILITY. TO
ALLOW THE CITY PASADENA TO
ESTABLISH AND TRANSFER
OWNERSHIP TO A CITY APPROVED
NONPROFIT HOUSINGRELATED
ENTITY THAT WOULD ACT AS A
STEWARD OVER THE PORTFOLIO- SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE HIS- A BILL
THAT'S ONLY BEEN SIX DECADES IN
THE MAKING. AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK IN GOOD
FAITH WITH ALL PARTIES I THINK
ONE OF THE KEY PIECES. IS THE
CURRENT TENANTS. RIGHT NOW HAVE
TO WAIT IN LINE. AND IMAGINE
BEING ONE OF THOSE TENTATIVE
LIVED IN GOOD STANDING IN ONE
OF THESE CALTRANS ON PROPERTY
SO WE'RE- INSURING THAT THE
TENANTS HAVE A BETTER PLACE IN
LINE TO PURCHASE THE HOMES THAT
THEY'VE BEEN OCCUPYING. AND
RUNNING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- FOR A LONG TIME SO-
WE'VE ALSO IKNOW PEOPLE OF
SAID WHY IS IT PASADENA IN THE
BILL. WE REACHED OUT TO THE
CITY OF PASADENA TO SEE- WITH
THEIR- DISPOSITION IS RELATED
TO THE HOMES AND THEIR PROPERTY
IN THEIR IN THEIR CITY. AND
WERE-HOPEFULLY TO GET A
RESPONSE FROM THEM RIGHT NOW
THE SUPPLY SPECIFICALLY. TO THE
CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA WHICH
PROACTIVELY WANTS TO ENGAGE
WHICH I THINK IS ALSO A GOOD
SIGN. BOTH FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE TENANTS
LIVING IN THE QUARTER. I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT DIANA MAHMUD WAS THE
MAYOR SOUTH PASADENA. AND ADAM.
WHO IS- WITH CONSULTING CIVIC
CENTER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE- ENSURE THAT
MAYOR MY MOOD. IS ON THE LINE
PLEASE. READ CHAIR MAMELODI ON
THE AS WELL AS- A AND I AM AND-
OKAY WE'LL START WITH OF THE
MAYOR FIRST PLEASE. THANK YOU
IN OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNOR NUISANCE FIND
LEGISLATION DISTRIBUTED THREE
ENDING SIX DECADES ATTEMPTED
CONSTRUCTION OF AN EXTENSION OF
THE STATE WHICH SEVEN TEN
FREEWAY THAT WOULD PASS THROUGH
THE STRUCTURE OF SOUTH
PASADENA. BUT THE THREAT OF THE
STREET WE EXTENSION BEHIND US
THE COMMUNITIES ATTENTION IS
NOW FOCUSED ON ACHIEVING AN
APPROPRIATE DISPOSITION OF
SURPLUS PROPERTY EXPECTS
CALTRANS ACCUMULATED OVER THAT
SAME PERIOD ALONG THE FORMER
EXTENSION GROUP'S. SOUTH
PASADENA HAS DELIVERED DECADES
OF BLIGHT AND TRACTORS NUISANCE
WHILE CALTRAIN CHASES AND EVER
PROMPTING ME TO REJECT DECADES
OF VARIOUS SAFETY AND RESPECT
CONSEQUENCES OF ITS LOCAL ACTED
PROPERTIES SOME OF WHICH ARE
HISTORIC. MANY OF THE SIXTY
EIGHT HOMES THAT REMAIN OWNED
BY CALTRANS IN MY CITY ARE
VACANT AND IN THE STATE OF
EXTREME DISREPAIR INDEED THE
STATUS NOW PAYING A SECURITY
FIRM TO GUARD THE TAKING HOMES
FROM FURTHER DAMAGE FOR ILLEGAL
OCCUPATION. MOREOVER FOR
DECADES SOUTH PASADENA SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DEPRIVED OF PROPERTY
TAX PROCEEDS FROM THESE TERMS
AS A SMALL CITY WITH NO MAJOR
COMMERCIAL. PROPERTY TAXES ARE
MY CITY'S PRIMARY SOURCE OF
REVENUE SHOULD THE COMMUNITY
DESIRES THAT CALTRANS REMOVED
ITSELF FROM THE HOUSING
BUSINESS AND ALLOW SOUTH
PASADENA TO EXPEDITIOUSLY
INITIATE LOCAL CONTROL AND
DETERMINE THE FAVORABLE
DISPOSITION STRATEGY FOR THE
HOMES. SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
PROVIDE THAT MUTUALLY.
ADVANTAGEOUS VEHICLE. EARLIER
THIS YEAR GENEVA. LET CAL THE
SEVEN DIRECT. AND HIS EXACT
MANAGE STAFF BASED FAVORABLY.
OUR COULD. THAT ALLOW CAL AND
SHOULD BE TO WORK. TO RESOLVE
THIS LAUNCHED PROBLEM I WOULD
LIKE TO NOW INTRODUCE ADAM.
HOUSING CONTROLLED YOU MISTER
IN SAN PACKAGE. WHO WILL
PRESENT A SUMMARY SB. EIGHTY
THANK MAYOR MAHMOUD OF
MODERATOR WILL MOVE OVER TO MR
ELLISON FROM CITY PM. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW YES WE CAN'T.
THANK YOU SB THREE ONE COME
JUST. WIN WIN PROPOSED TO A
PROBLEM PLAGUED CALTRAIN AND
THE OF PASSED FOR. I OFFERED
FOLLOWING SOME OF THE POINT TO
WHAT SB ONE PROVIDES NUMBER
ONE. THREE ONE WITH MABEL
CURRENT TENANTS AN ABSOLUTE
PRIORITY TO PURCHASE A HOME IN
WHICH THEY'D RENTED FROM
CALTRANS THE PURCHASE PRICE
WOULD REMAIN AS CURRENTLY
SPECIFIED IN LAW. NUMBER TWO IS
A KEY TENER DOES NOT. OR
CHOOSES NOT TO PURCHASE SB
THREE ONE WOULD ALLOW THE CITY.
PURCHASED THE PROPERTIES AT THE
CALTRANS ACQUISITION PRICE MAKE
ALL THE NECESSARY REPAIRS AND
RENT THE PROPERTY BACK TO THE
CURRENT TENANT AND THE AMOUNT
APPROPRIATE TO THEIR INCOME
CATEGORY. NUMBER THREE SB THREE
ONE WOULD ALLOW THE CITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE ALL
UNOCCUPIED PROPERTIES. AT THE
CALTRANS ACQUISITION PRICE.
THIS PRICE ALLOWS THE CITY TO
FINANCE THE SUBSTANTIAL REPAIRS
AND OFFER THEM FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH A COVENANT FOR
SIXTY FIVE YEARS. THANKS FOR SB
THREE ONE WHILE THE CITY TO
ESTABLISH AND TRANSFER
OWNERSHIP TO THE CITY APPROVED
HOUSING RELATED ENTITY THAT
WOULD ACT AS A STEWARD OVER THE
PORTFOLIO SURPLUS PROPERTIES
ENSURE RESPONSIVE PROPERTY
MAINTENANCE AND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
ONE WOULD REQUIRE ALL THE
PROCEEDS FROM THE CITY SALES TO
BE USED FOR LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING IN THE CITY.
NUMBER SIX SB THREE ONE PUTS A
TIME FRAME CALTRANS THE CURRENT
TENANTS AND THE CITY TO
COMPLETE THE SALE PROCESS. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR REMARKS AND WE
THANK SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
HIS STRONG SUPPORT SOUTH
PASADENA IS AFTER TO RETURN
LOCAL CONTROL TO THE CITY FOR
THESE PROPERTIES. THAT HAVE
LONG BEEN KNOWN BY THE STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER. ALL RIGHT
WILL CONTINUE ON WITH US
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- TO SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY OUR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE MODERATOR FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
WILL MOVE OVER TWENTY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE- MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
REGISTERED LEAD OPPOSITION BUT
I DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION TO THREE
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR AND I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY NO ONE AND ONE
TWELVE FOR OPPOSITION AND- TO
SB THREE EIGHTY ONE SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED THAT LOOK WILL BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS.
AND I HAVE SENATOR DOLLY AND
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL I LIKE IT I JUST HAD A
QUESTION NO ONE I KNOW THAT-
SENATOR DORADO HAD A SIMILAR
BILL EARLIER THIS YEAR. BUT THE
PEOPLE THAT LOST THEIR HOME
ORIGINALLY- AND I THINK THIS
PROCESS WAS THROUGH EMINENT
DOMAIN DO THEY HAVE ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE BACK
WHAT THEY- THE- IN THE IN THIS
PROCESS JUST A QUESTION I WAS
THINKING ABOUT- THOSE WHO
MIGHT. YOU KNOW PROBABLY DIDN'T
WANT TO MOVE AT THE TIME THAT
EMINENT DOMAIN ALLOW FOR THE
ACCESS- BUT COMING BACK NOW
MANY YEARS LATER IS THERE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE FOLKS TO.
ACCESS WHAT THE WAS THERE'S
ORIGINALLY. NO I ACTUALLY. I
DON'T KNOW- I DON'T THINK SO I
MEAN WHAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
IS THERE'S BEEN TENANTS THAT
HAVE BEEN LIVING IN THERE FOR
THREE DECADES SO WE'VE BEEN PUT
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT THAT EXISTING TENANTS
DON'T GET THIS PLACE TO HAVE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN GOOD
STANDING IN THE PURCHASE THE
HOMES THAT THEY'VE BEEN RENTING
FOR DECADES. PURSES THOSE FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAD NEGOTIATED THE
SETTLEMENTS BACK WHEN EMINENT
DOMAIN WHICH IS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLARS
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- WE SHARE SEVEN TEN
CORRIDOR AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TYPE I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA FOR WANTING TO AND
BASS YOU KNOW THESE AREAS HAVE
SO MUCH POTENTIAL. AS I HEARD-
FROM ONE AT THE SUPPORTERS ARE
WILLING TO INVEST IN THE
REPAIRS AND MAKING SURE THAT IF
FAMILIES ARE NOT ABLE TO DO SO
THAT THAT THE CITY TAKES ON
THAT CHALLENGE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THIS DESPERATELY NEEDED
SOUL I REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
EFFORTS SELF WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR IN MADAM
CHAIR IF I COULD GO BACK A I
HAD A BRAIN FREEZE. YES THOSE
FORMER TENANTS ARE FIRST IN
LINE INTO A FORMER OWNERS HAVE
HAVE STANDING AS WELL GREAT I
KNOW YOU MIGHT THAT. UNDER I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN ON THAT AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE MIKE UP SENATOR
ARCHULETA. YES I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR CHEN GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE FAMILIES
AND BEEN THERE. AS YOU
MENTIONED AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS
OR SO. BUT IF THERE'S SOMEONE
THERE THERE WAS BEEN THERE THAT
LONG THEY MAY NOW BE SENIORS.
AND MAY NOT QUALIFY- WITH YOUR
LOW INCOME OR WHATEVER WOULD
BE. WITH A FAMILY MEMBER BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. CHAU BACK
PURCHASE COULD BE MADE WITHIN
THE FAMILY. SENATOR UP
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT. WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR PROPER
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE SO NOBODY
GAMES THE SYSTEM- THAT'S WHY
INCOME LEVELS ARE BEING-
PROCESS THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
THERE YOU KNOW HE BY THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE THERE
HAS TO BE THE COVENANTS OF THE
BUYING A LOW INCOME-
ELIGIBILITY YOU HAVE TO MEET
INCOME STANDARD SO. I DON'T
BELIEVE YOU CAN USE SOMEONE
ELSE'S INCOME STANDARD TO SORT
OF INSIUATED INTO THE SYSTEM-
I'M GETTING A TEXT HOLD ON LET
ME SEE. WHAT I'M BEING TOLD- I
BELIEVE THERE IS A PROCESS IN
PLACE TO ALLOW IT BUT IT HAS TO
BE WITH SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE NOT GAMING THE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA I SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I JUST WHEN I THINK
YOU SAID IN A PORTANTINO I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
SOME TIME- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YEAH I MEAN IT'S- I'VE
ONLY BEEN ADDED FOR THREE
DECADES BUT THEIR FOLKS WHO'VE
BEEN AT IT FOR A FOR SIX PLUS.
AND THIS IS REALLY A SENSITIVE
WAY TO TRY TO- MAINTAIN THE-
INTEGRITY OF THOSE. TENANTS IN
THE CORRIDOR. TO GIVE SOUTH
PASADENA AND ABILITY TO HAVE
SOME LOCAL SHEPHERDING ABILITY
VERSUS CALTRANS. TO PARTNER
WITH NONPROFITS TO ENSURE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I THINK
WE'RE ON A PATH TO A GOOD
SOLUTION. SO THANK YOU AND THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO S. IT'S
A MOTION ON SB. THREE EIGHTY
ONE- MISTER CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI BATES.
HI BATES HI ALLEN. AYE FELON
AYE ARCHULETA AYE WHICH LED A
HIGH BAKER HI. HI CORTESE.
CORTESEHI DOLLY HI KELLY HI
DOT HI DOT HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
HI BELINDA'S MAN ALL RIGHT HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HOMBURG HI
NUMBER A GUY BY CASKEY HI
KELSEY HI WILK. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO LOOKS LIKE THE
BILL ITSELF BUT WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL AS WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR DINO GREAT OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON OUR NEXT PRESENTERS
SENATOR MELENDEZ FOR SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX AND YOU CAN PRESENT
AT YOUR DESK IF YOU'D LIKE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON- SENATORS. SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX EXTENDS THE VALIDITY
VALIDITY OF A CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS FROM
FIVE YEARS TO EIGHT BEFORE
REQUIRING A RENEWAL THESE TIME
FRAMES WOULD APPLY TO ANY
DRIVER AGE TWENTY FIVE TO
SEVENTY HOWEVER I AM COMMITTED
TO TAKING AMENDMENTS IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE SHOULD THIS BILL
PASS TODAY. THAT WOULD MERE
EXISTING LAW BY APPLYING THIS
TIME FOR A BIT INSTEAD TO
DRIVERS AGE SIXTEEN TO SEVENTY
THERE BY NOT CREATING TWO TIERS
SENATORS WE'VE ALL HEARD THE
HORROR STORIES ABOUT THE WAIT
TIMES AT THE DMV FROM LONG WAIT
TIMES TO GET APPOINTMENTS TO NO
APPOINTMENTS BEING AVAILABLE IN
THE PREHISTORIC TECHNOLOGY
CURRENTLY EXISTING AT THE DMV.
NOT TO MENTION INCREDIBLY LONG
WAIT TIMES WERE DURING THE HOT
SUMMER MONTHS. PEOPLE HAVE
PASSED OUT PEOPLE THAT NEED TO
BE. HAVE NEDED TO BE GIVEN
WATER IT'S- I KNOW YOU'VE ALL
SEEN THE STORIES AND AS SOMEONE
WHO REPRESENTS THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN THE DESERT OASIS THAT
IS KNOWN AS PALM SPRINGS
THERMAL IN COACHELLA VALLEY. I
CAN TELL YOU IT IS INCREDIBLY
HOT OUT THERE AND UNCOMFORTABLE
TO STAND IN LINE. OVER THE PAST
YEAR WE HAVE SEEN DRIVERS
LICENSES EXTENDED ONLINE
PRIMARILY DUE TO PANDEMIC.
THESE EXTENSIONS ARE ALSO
GRANTED HOWEVER BECAUSE THE DMB
SYSTEMS WERE NOT CAPABLE OF
HANDLING THE TREMENDOUS INFLUX
OF PEOPLE WHO NEEDED TO OBTAIN
A REAL ID. REGISTER THEIR
VEHICLE- OR TRANSFER TITLES.
THE PROBLEMS THAT PLAGUE DID
DMB ARE NOT NEW. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN AN AUDIT OF THE DMV
THE LONG WAIT TIMES IN BOTCHED
VOTER REGISTRATION AND THREE
YEARS LATER WE ARE STILL IN THE
SAME SPOT. THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL AIMED AT ALLEVIATING
SOME OF THE LOG JAM AT THE DMV.
AND WITH ANOTHER POTENTIAL REAL
ID COMPLIANCE GRIDLOCK ON THE
HORIZON WE REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE TERMS ARE GOING TO LOOK
TOUGH. WHAT WAIT TIMES ARE
GOING TO LOOK LIKE. SO I WOULD
SAY IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
REDUCING UNNECESSARY VISITS
INDIAN BE WOULD BENEFIT
EVERYONE- I HAVE A WITNESS ON
THE PHONE HOPEFULLY SHE'S THERE
NOW TO TESTIFY WHEN THE BUYERS.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELENDEZ MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE- ENSURE THAT WHEN THE
FIRE IS ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR EIGHTY SIX. I JUST
GOT A TEXT THAT THE PHONE
SYSTEM KICKED HEROFF SO SHE'S
CALLING BACK IN SO- HOPEFULLY
SHE GETS BACK ON SOON. OKAY
GREAT. WAIT JUST ANOTHER SECOND
HERE. MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
LET US KNOW WHEN MS WHEN THE
FIRE IS ON THE LINE. YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT WE
WILL MOVE THE LINE RATE.
THE
MODERATOR TO HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD
WE ARE STILL WAITING WITH A
WINDY- ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY
WHY DON'T WE MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT UNLESS WE
THINK WORK SHE'S GOING TO BE
RIGHT BACK. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX ON THE LINE. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST
NINE. NINE SIXTY SIX. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ONE
SIXTY SIX IS THIS IS SENATOR
MELINDA SPELL FORTY SIX YES
THIS IS PLEASE GO AHEAD PLEASE
LET US KNOW YOUR NAME OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION HAVING SOME
PROBLEMS I SUPPORT THIS BILL
VERY STRONGLY AND I I'M NOT
VERY HAPPY THAT THE PHONES ARE
HAVING SOME DIFFICULTIES
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
CALL IN SO IF YOU COULD NOT THE
RECORD. I SUPPORT THIS BILL IN
YOUR FOUNDER A TOTAL AND
COMPLETE. YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS TERRY ART AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TO CHANGE
THE LICENSING FROM FIVE YEARS
TO EIGHT YEARS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE AND MODERATOR IF WE HAVE
MISSED BY ARE ON THE LINE
PLEASE LET US KNOW AS WELL.
THANK YOU NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY WELL NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND SENATOR
MY NAME IS WENDY BUYER AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I
RECENTLY MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
AND HAD TO WAIT TWICE IN THE
SUN DOWN HERE- AND I THINK
THAT'S ENOUGH FOR PEOPLE IF YOU
WERE I THINK THE DMV IS
BACKLOGGED- AND IT WOULD
PROTECT BOTH THE DMV TO CATCH
UP. AND IT WOULD PROTECT THE
DMB FROM FURTHER- EXPOSURE TO
VIRUSES AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC
TO VIRUSES THEY'VE DONE THIS
SUCCESSFULLY NEW YORK THEY'VE
DONE IT SUCCESSFULLY IN ARIZONA
AND NEW YORK CERTAINLY HAS THE
TRAFFIC PROBLEMS THAT WE DO I
THINK WE COULD DO THIS WITHOUT-
WITHOUT ANY WITHOUT ANY HURT TO
THEIR LOCAL TRAFFIC- I AM. IT
IT'S IT WENT THE LEVY EIGHT
HAVING TO GO SO OFTEN TO THE
DMV TO HAVE THINGS ACCOMPLISHED
SO I AM VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND- I THINK YOU
SHOULD PASS IT. THANK YOU
MISFIRE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYMORE A TESTIMONY. MY
APOLOGIES ANYMORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY SIX. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY SIX
OKAY THANK YOU- LOOKING BOTH TO
ONE MOMENT WHILE I'M SORRY WE
DO HAVE LINE SIXTY TWO. POINT
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF THIS LINE
SIXTY TWO I'M HI MY NAME IS I'M
A GAS IS THIS LIKE SIXTY TWO I
SUPPORTED BILL YOUR PHONE LINES
ARE TERRIBLE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO QUEUE UP AND THEY CAN'T GET
THROUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
INTERPRET THE MPS SO YOU NEED A
PATH THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. WE JUST NEED
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
SIX. ARE THERE ANY OVER THE
LINE FROM THE SUPPORT. OKAY NO
OTHER LINES OF SUPPORT. THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR ONE LOOKING TO
GALLERY THERE ARE NO AT PEOPLE
IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT ROOM
ONE TWELVE EIGHTY NINE. WE'LL
TAKE IT TO OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION
BUT ARE THERE ANY. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY THERE'S
NINE ONE TWELVE WE SEE NONE.
AND IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE. IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FORTY SIX MODERATOR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FORTY SIX MAIN PRESS ONE.
AND THEN TO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SB
FORTY SIX OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR SO IF INCLUDED
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO. MEMBERS AND
I'LL START BY SAYING. YOU KNOW
I APPRECIATE THAT THE
DISCUSSION HERE- CENTER
MELENDEZ CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERNS I THINK MANY OF US
DO- REGARDING THE DMV HOWEVER.
WE HAVE AN IMPENDING DEADLINE
OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOR
REAL ID ON TOP OF THE PANDEMIC
SO. I THINK THAT OVERHAULING
RIGHT NOW MAY BE. A TOUGH TIME
FOR US TO DO THAT IN ADDITION
TO THE FACT THAT IT DID IT IN
THE ORIGINAL FORM THAT YOU HAD
CREATED ON THE BLL LANGUAGE.
IT DID CREATE A TWO TIER SYSTEM
SO I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU BE
AMENABLE SHOULD THIS PASS- FOR
THAT. AND LASTLY THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. PROBLEMS THERE
TOO IT'S ON THE PATH OF A
NEGATIVE BALANCE UNFORTUNATELY.
SO THIS WOULD JUST FURTHER
EXACERBATE YOU KNOW THE LACK OF
FUNDING IN THAT. SO WITH THAT I
WILL BE OPPOSED TODAY BUT WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU OVERALL-
TO SEE IF WE CAN GET SOMEWHERE.
LATER ON. WITH THAT I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
OTHER SENATORS. CASEY NINE
SENATOR MELENDEZ WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. AT WHAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND I'M CERTAINLY
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
JUST. WANT TO POINT OUT A
COUPLE THINGS- SINCE THERE WAS
NO DISCUSSION OR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE BILL- IN THE ANALYSIS
IT. TALKS ABOUT THAT THERE
MIGHT BE A FINANCIAL IMPACT TO
THE NBA BUT IT IS UNKNOWN-
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT THE FEE.
IS SET TO COVERED THE SERVICES
RENDERED SO IF YOU PER YOU ARE
PROVIDING. LESS OF THAT SERVICE
THAN THE COST TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE ALSO DECREASESSO
THERE'S NOT. ANY DECREASE- OF
FUNDING. NECESSARILY TO THAT
ACCOUNT BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU WOULD BE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES OUT AS OFTEN I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT- IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT TALKS ABOUT- THIS C. H. P.
FUNDING. PLEASE ALSO NOTE THAT
THE FUNDING FOR CHP COMES FROM
THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEE
NOT FROM YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE
FEE. AT ALL- HI YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS AND
WE'VE PASSED A LOT OF POLICY
HERE DESIGNED TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO- KIND OF COME BACK INTO THE
ECONOMY AND REGAIN SOME OF WHAT
THEY'VE LOST OVER THE PAST
YEAR. AND I'VE SUPPORTED
THERE'S ACTIONS AND BUT I THINK
WE CAN GO FURTHER AND HELPING
PEOPLE IN THE LONG TERM BY
TAKING A SMALL STEP OF ALLOWING
THEM TO RENEW TEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE AFTER EIGHT YEARS LIKE
MANY OTHER STATES DO RATHER
THAN JUST FIVE YEARS THAT IS
NOT- IT'S NOT A BURDEN TO THE
STATE'S BUDGET IN DOING SO. I
THINK CALIFORNIANS WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK THE DMB WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE IT
MEANS FEWER PEOPLE COMING IN
FOR SERVICES WHICH MEANS THEY
CAN THEN DIRECT THEIR ATTENTION
TO THOSE WHO NEED TO GET THEIR
REAL ID WE NEED TO GET A NEW
LICENSE ARE A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER SERVICES THAT THE DMB
PROVIDES- SO WITH THAT MANAGER
I WOULD- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. IN CASE. MELINDA.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB. FOUR
EIGHTY SIX REVERSION BY SENATOR
DOLLY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CONSULTING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AS
BEFORE EIGHTY SIX. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CONSULTS NOW AND SALAS NO BATES
HI BATES HI ELLEN. SUCH A
LETTER. BAKER CORTESE NO
CORTESE NOW DOLLY HI DOLLY HI
DOT HI DODD HI MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ AYE MIN.
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO.
SKINNER HUMBERT. MICHALSKI NO.
SO I COUNTY LIKE US YOU KNOW.
WELL. FIVE THREE OKAY FIVE
THREE WILLLEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR MELENDEZ.
NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON TO I'M NOT
SURE IF SENATORS STERN IS ON
THELINE HE IS NOT OKAY. WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
SENATOR NEWMAN TO PRESENT SB
FIVE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE. MY
OWN THANK YOU MAN I'M SURE YOU
CAUGHT ME OFF GUARD I WAS JUST
FINISHING MUFFIN I APOLOGIZE.
ONE SECOND. YEAH GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED IN MEMBERS I'M HERE
BEFORE TODAY TO PRESENT SB FIVE
EIGHT THREE WHICH BUILDS ON
CALIFORNIA'S NEW MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM IN RECENT COMPLIANCE
UPGRADES RESULTING FROM A
MANDATORY TRANSITION TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S REAL ID
SYSTEM TO STREAMLINE NEW
REGISTRATIONS AND REGISTRATION
UPDATES OF STATE AGENCIES.
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF SB FIVE
EIGHT THREE AN UNREGISTERED
ELIGIBLE DAHLE WHO IS VERIFIED
AS A CITIZEN DURING AN AGENCY
TRANSACTION WILL BE
AUTOMATICALLY ADDED TO VOTER.
NAME DETAILS UPDATED BASED ON
INFORMATION PROVIDED DURING A
TYPICAL AGENCY TRANSACTION TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS TASK SB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE ADULTS WHAT IS
CALLED A BACKEND AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM KNOWN
COMMONLY AS A VR AT THE DMV AND
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO BE
AUTHORIZED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE UNDER THIS LEGISLATION IN
A BACK IN AB OUR SYSTEM A
VOTING AGE PERSON WHO IS
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE BUT NOT
CURRENTLY REGISTERED AND WHO
PROVIDES PROOF OF US
CITIZENSHIP DURING THEIR DMP
TRANSACTION. WOULD HAVE THEIR
INFORMATION AUTOMATICALLY
PASSED ON TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO BE ADDED TO THE VOTER
ROLLS THE PERSON WOULD NOT NEED
TO REQUEST REGISTRATION OR
INTEREST CITIZENSHIP QUESTION
DURING THE DMV TRANSACTION
INSTEAD THE CITIZENSHIP
DOCUMENTS THEY PRESENT AS PART
OF THE APPLICABLE DMV
TRANSACTIONS PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY AT A STATION OF
CITIZENSHIP AND REGISTRATION
ELIGIBILITY TO PROTECT NON
CITIZENS THE BACK AND IF YOUR
SERVICES SYSTEM SCREENS OUT DMV
CUSTOMERS FOR APPLICANTS FOR AN
AB SIXTY. WHICH IS USED BY
UNDER AND OR WHO PROVIDED
DOCUMENTS ESTABLISHING FORMS
SUCH AS A GREEN CARD UNDER THE
BACK IN AB ARE SO PROVIDE FOR
BY- JUST BE FIVE EIGHT THREE A
PURSE WHO BRIDGE PROOF OF IT
WOULD HAVE THEIR INFORMATION
AUTOMATICALLY TRANSMITTED
SECTOR STATE FOR INCLUSION N
THE VOTER ROLLS ONCE THE
SECULAR STATE REGISTERS AN
ELIGIBLE DMV CUSTOMER THE
COUNTY REGISTER OF VOTERS
WITHIN MAIL THE NEWLY
REGISTERED VOTERS A NOTICE OF
REGISTRATION AS REQUIRED UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. IN THIS MAIL
NOTICE WOULD PROVIDE THE PERSON
A CHANCE TO DECLINE
REGISTRATION BY RELYING ON
VERIFY DOCUMENTS PRESENTED IN
THE COURSE OF THE DMV
TRANSACTION BACK IN AB YOUR
WILL REDUCE HUMAN ERROR
SIGNIFICANTLY WHILE ALSO
MINIMIZING THE LIKELIHOOD OF
UNINTENTIONALLY FALSE CLAIMS OF
CITIZENSHIP BY APPLICANTS THIS
APPROACH TO VOTER REGISTRATIONS
ALREADY BEING USED EFFECTIVELY
IN OTHER STATES COLORADO AND
OREGON USED BACK AND IF YOU'RE
SYSTEMS IN ALASKA MASSACHUSETTS
AND NEVADA HAVE RECENTLY
AUTHORIZED SIMILAR PROCEDURES.
EVIDENCE FROM THE STATE SO FAR
SHOWS THAT BACK AND IF YOUR
WORKS DATA FROM COLORADO.
INDICATES THAT LOW S. THAN 1%
OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS WHO EACH MAY
TO CLIMB REGISTRY.
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE OF L.
SERVICE WHO ARE. TO VOTE UNDER
THIS ONLY ELLA STUDENTS WHO
WITH. CHIU NOT TO BE REGISTER
AS VOTERS. WILL OPT OUT. BY CA.
LARGE NUMBERS ILLEGAL CITIZENS
ARE BUSY. CONFUSED- ON ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS TO A PRO CAN. WIND
UP DECLINING READY. DURING THE
TRANS UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM
BUT WHO OTHERWISE WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE. BACK IN AB
ARE ALSO PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS THAT INCLUDE COST
SAVINGS STREAMLINED DMV
TRANSACTIONS IMPROVED ALREADY
CAPABILITY BY MAXIMIZING
AUTOMATION. AND MAKING RIGHTS
RESTORATION EFFECTIVE FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED. A
VALID GOAL OF EIGHTY
REGISTRATION SHOULD BE THE
REGISTRATION OF AS MANY
ELIGIBLE CITIZENS AS POSSIBLE
WHILE SCREENING OUT AND
PROTECTING NON CITIZENS FROM
IMPROPER OR INADVERTENT
REGISTRATION. BY RELYING ON
INFORMATION THAT IS ALREADY
BEING PRESENTED VERIFIED AND
RECORDED IN THE NORMAL COURSE
OF AN AG TRANSACTION.
CALIFORNIA CAN CREATE MORE
ACCURATE AND COMPLETE VOTER
ROLLS REDUCE HUMAN ERROR AND
MAXIMIZE SAFEGUARDS FOR
NONCITIZENS INTERACTING WITH
THESE AGENCIES. I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING
DRAFT AMENDMENTS THAT REQUIRE
THE POST TRANSACTION MAILER TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SELECT A LANGUAGE PREFERENCE.
AND TO ENSURE THAT VOTED BE
PROVIDED INFORMATION ON HOW TO
OBTAIN IN LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE.
WITH ME TODAY VIRTUALLY
TESTIFIED NEIL- BRIANNA FROM
THIS. FOR SECURE AND MODERN
ELECTIONS WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE I HUMBLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE ENSURE THAT MISTER.
LIU BRITTANI IS ON THE- IN
SUPPORT OFSB. FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LANDED OPEN. GOOD MORNING TERRY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NEIL
BROWNING AND RESEARCH FOR AT
THE FOR SECURITY WATER ELECTION
YES AND. EIGHT THE NATIONAL NON
CAN SUPPORT STATE IN MAKING.
FOR ACCEPTABLE EFFICIENCY I'M
HERE SUPPORT SB FIVE THREE
WHICH UPGRADE THE AUTO. VOTER
SYSTEM A CALIFORNIA CAN BE BACK.
AS IT USED BY ORGAN COLORADO IT
THERE AGAIN. MACINNES YOU'RE
RELIED ON THE. ALREADY
REGISTERED TO VOTE THEY'RE
AUTOMATICALLY FILTER INTO THE
REGISTRATION PROCESS. PAPER I
COULD NON CITIZENSHIP ARE
AUTOMATICALLYFILTERED OUT.
THIS IS TO PROVIDE SEVERAL
BENEFITS OVER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. FIRST BACK AND IF
YOU'RE REGISTERED MORE PEOPLE
TO VOTE. FOR ROUGHLY 45% OF THE
INDIE CUSTOMERS ARE DECLINING
REGISTRATION UNDER CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT SYSTEM. THE NATION
REFER BACK INTO MAILERS IN
COLORADO OR 1% SECOND BACK AND
IF YOU'RE CREE FOR ACTOR
REGISTRATION RECORDS BY
AUTOMATICALLY UPDATING ADDRESS
THE NAME INFORMATION PROVIDED
AT THE DMV. AFTER REGISTRATION
RECORDS STATE TIME AND MONEY BY
PREVENTING UNDELIVERABLE MAIL
INCLUDING MAILED OUT. AND
REDUCING TIME SPENT UPDATING
INFORMATION AT THE POLL. THIRD
ACTIVATE YOUR- ENHANCED
PROTECTIONS FOR NONPARTISAN. BY
RELYING ON DOCUMENTATION AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE BACK IN A YEAR
LIMITS THE RISK OF HUMAN ERROR.
BUT BACK IN EIGHTY OUR IDEA
BECAUSE AMERICA PRESENTED
DOCUMENT ESTABLISHING ON
CITIZENSHIP LIKE A GREEN CARD
DURING THE DRIVER'S LICENSES
TRANSACTION. IT AUTOMATICALLY
FILTERED OUT OF VOTER
REGISTRATION APARTMENT NOT
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
MISTAKE ON CITIZENSHIP AND
VOTER REGISTRATION QUESTIONS.
DURING THE IN THE TRANSACTION.
CATASTROPHIC IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISS BROWN- NEXT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO SOME WITNESSES
AND GALLERY. THE NINE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE C. NINE. A MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS RESPONSIVE PART THAT WE
GET THE LESSONS AND I'M ALL
POVERTY WITHOUT IT BECAUSE
MONSTER. THANK YOU. NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
PART OF A COVER WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS
WORKING ENVIRONMENT R. CALLING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE SEE NOTHING NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION ARE THERE
ANY- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
FIVE EIGHTY THREE IN THE
GALLERY WE SEE NINE. ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE SEE NINE MODERATOR
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE FOR SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
GENERAL AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. S. ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LIN IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY
SIX I REMEMBER TO RUN IN OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO COMMENT
PLEASE. THEY'RE NOT FOR COMMENT
IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MODERATOR SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
DOLLY. THE MANAGER MEMBERS AS
WE JUST HEARD A BILL. THAT
DIDN'T GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE OR STILL ON CALL NANA
BOATS THAT REQUIRE THE DMV TO
ACTUALLY DO LESS WORK. THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE DMV TO DO
MORE WORK AND I JUST WANT TO
SHARE A PERSONAL STORY ONE OF
MY- SON'S FRIENDS WHO TURNED
SIXTEEN LAST YEAR. WHEN I GOT
HIS DRIVER'S LICENSE AND HE
ACTUALLY GOT A BALLOT I. HE
SAID I CAN VOTE FOR YOU AND YOU
SIXTEEN SO THERE ARE SOME
PROBLEMS WITH. OUR I. T. AT THE
DMV THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT-
AND THIS IS JUST GONNA ADD MORE
TO IT. AND I AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS WITH THE DMV WE'VE SEEN IT
WITH THE E. D. D. WHERE WE HAVE
HUGE PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE THE LEADER. IN THE NATION
WHEN IT COMES TO TECHNOLOGY
COMING OUT OF OUR STATE. ON THE
PRIVATE SIDE OF FOR SOME REASON
WE SURE CAN'T SEEING HOW TO.
FIGURE OUT TO GET. GOOD- I. T.
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE AGENCIES
THAT WORK FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
THIS AND MANY MORE REASONS I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS. PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THANK YOU. VICE
CHAIR BATES DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION AS WELL. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE OKAY GO RIGHT AHEAD
JUST A COMMENT I WANT TO THINK
OF. SENATOR ANA. NEWSOME
NEWMAN. NEWMAN FINANCIALLY
TODAY. I FOR. A THE ISSUE OF
OPTING OUT IN OPTING IN I HAD
TO- A COUPLE YEARS AGO I THINK
I WAS TWENTY SEVENTEEN TRYING
TO DETERMINE A WAY TO. PROVIDE
AN OPT OUT. OF ICON ON THE
SCREEN SHOT THAT YOU HAVE A DMV
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE- PROBLEMS
THAT THAT- EMANATED FROM THE
ROLL OUT OF FIVE THE MOTOR
VOTER- I. ACTUALLY HAD SOME-
INTERESTED IN MAKING IT MORE OF
A- OF A FIX AT TO DMB AND
SECRETARY OF STATE RATHER THAN
LEGISLATION SO I'D LIKE TO HAVE
A FURTHER DISCUSSION. WITH US
SENATOR- AND I MENTIONED THAT
TO HIM SO THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
WHAT I WAS PROPOSING. AND HOW
THAT MIGHT BE FOLDED AND
THROUGH SOME AMENDMENT PROCESS
ON THIS ONE BECAUSE I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OPT OUT THIS
SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE
COMPLICATED KNOWING THAT DMB
HAS HAD PROBLEMS. WITH OF THEIR
OB TECHNICAL. CONNECTION TO
SECRETARY OF STATE BUT I THINK
IT'S WORTH A DISCUSSION BECAUSE
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH PEOPLE. WHO ARE REGISTERED
TO- INACCURATELY THEY WOULD BE
WHETHER BE IN THE OTHER PARTY
AND I THINK MANY OF OUR OFFICES
WERE INUNDATED INITIALLY. ARE
WITH SOME OF THE ERRORS THAT
OCCURRED SO. I THINK IT'S GOOD
TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT AND I
INTEND TO DO THAT. THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR BATES SENATOR
ARCHULETA. YES THANK YOU AND
CHAIR. I'D LIKE TO.
CONGRATULATIONS THE AUTHOR WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- TO
EVERYONE. THE FACT IS THAT WE
NOW CAN ALL- GET PEOPLE TO VOTE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS THERE.
IN IS ALWAYS THE OPTION. IN
WITH THIS BILL AS THEY REGISTER
FOR THE ROOM THEIR LICENSE AND
SO ON THE INFORMATION IS TAKEN.
AND THEN IT AS IT GOES THROUGH
THE SYSTEM AT THE VERY END. THE
PERSON IS ELIGIBLE TO VOTE
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPTION TO DO
THAT. AND WITH THIS WE'RE
HOPING THAT- BEFORE FOUR SIX
MILLION PEOPLE THAT. PERHAPS
WILL VOTE NOT VOTE WHATEVER
WILL BE ENCOURAGED TO VOTE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THE BILL I'D LOVE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR. I THINK IT IT SENDS
A MESSAGE THAT WE ALWAYS WANT
EVERYONE TO BE GIVEN THAT
OPTION TO VOTE AND- WHAT A
GREAT WAY TO DO IT. AND WITH
THAT I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU SENATE ARCHULETA SENATOR
MEN. I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF CENTER. AND APPLIED
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ULLERTON FOR
PUSHING THIS BILL AT A TIME
WHEN. I TOO MANY STATE
LEGISLATURES AROUND THE COUNTRY
ARE TRYING TO SUPPRESS VOTER
PARTICIPATION. I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE AS
CONTINUE TO LEAD IN THIS
COUNTRY- AND YOU KNOW EMPHASIZE
THE VERY FIRST PRINCIPLE OF
DEMOCRACY WHICH IS VOTER
PARTICIPATION. AND SO- I WOULD
ALSO ASK YOU MADE A CO AUTHOR
AT THE EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY I
SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
IS A THOUGHTFUL BILL- AND IT'S
IT REPRESENTS THE VALUES THAT
MADE THIS COUNTRY WHAT IT IS.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN. ARE
RIGHT SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP
SENATOR NEWMAN I ALSO WANNA
COOK COMMEND YOU FOR BY DOING
THIS BILL- CERTAINLY WILL
EXPAND VOTER ACCESS AS WE ALL
HAVE MENTIONED- I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY THAT YOU WILL BE TAKING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THAT
IS CORRECT MANAGER GREAT THANK
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE I WOULD. TO THANK YOU-
SPECIALLY CENTER ARCHULETA
SENTIMENTAL AT TO ADD YOU. AS
CO AUTHORS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. AND THANK YOU TO
CENTER BASIS UNDER DOLLARS FOR
YOUR YOURTHOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
AS WELL. I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT BUT ON THE ONE HAND- CENTER
BATES GLAD TO CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION- BUT TO SENATOR
DOLLY YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN-
IN ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS SYSTEM
IS USED TO TAKE. HUMAN ERROR
OUT OF THE EQUATION I THINK THE
SITUATION YOU DESCRIBE MANY OF
US HAVEHEARD- WITH- MISTAKES
IN THE NAME OVER AND OVER MOTOR
VOTER PROCESS. THAT HAVE BEEN
MOSTLY DUE TO HUMAN ERROR- MORE
IMPORTANTLY- AS THE WITNESS
NOTED. THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
NONCITIZENS. WHO HAVE. INCLUDE
WHO CAN BECOME- AND THE CURRENT
PRO. THAT THEY'VE FOUND
THEMSELVES IN SUBSTANTIAL LEGAL
JEOPARDY- BY NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN AND AUTOMATING THIS PROCESS
WOULD SOLVE THAT PROBLEM IT
WOULD ALSO HELP. TO HELP OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE ELIGIBLE
FOR REINSTATEMENT OF FOLKS-
RETURNED TO THE RULES- AND WE
FIND THAT IN MANY CASES THEY'RE
EITHER UNCLEAR. OR NERVOUS
ABOUT MAKING THAT STEP SO THAT
THE SYSTEM WOULD HELP AS WELL.
MORE IMPORTANTLY OVERTIME THEY
SHOULD SAVE TIME AND MONEY FOR
THE DMV- OBVIOUSLY THE DMV IS A
COMPLEX- AND LARGE AND ALSO
CENTRAL BUREAUCRACY INTERSTATE-
INTO IMPLEMENTATION IS NO SMALL
THING. BUT S WE MOVE FORWARD-
THERE ARE A HOST OF BENEFITS
AND I THINK AS YOU HEARD THE
STATE OF COLORADO. HAS ALREADY
SEEN THOSE BENEFITS IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. FOR
COLORADO JENA GRISWOLD. I HAS
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH OUR
SECRETARY STRAIGHT DR SHIRLEY
WEBER- AND THEY SHARED
INFORMATION A DOCTOR WEBER. SO
FAR AS ENCOURAGED AND WILL BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH HER OFFICE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR NEWMAN DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. ON SB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE. MOVE BY SENATOR
ARCH. THANK YOU MISTER
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE DALLAS FIVE DOLLARS AYE
BATES. HELEN ARCHULETA HIGH
WHICH LED A HIGH BAKER HI HI
CORTESE CORTESE I DOLLY GO
BELLY NOW DONE HI DON I MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ. MAN ALL RIGHT MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER GUY BY COUNTY HI KELSEY
I WILL. TEN ONE TEN ONE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN AND WELCOME
SENATOR WESSEL. AND HE'LL BE
PRESENTING ON SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES REFLECT
THE NEED TO GROW IN STATE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND WORKFORCE
EQUITY THERE'S BEEN A
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
TAKING IT FOR YEARS AND YEARS
HOW WOULD THE GOAL IN
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE TO ENSURE
THAT THE CLEAN ENERGY
REVOLUTION HERE IN OUR STATE-
IS EQUITABLE INCLUDES ALL
PEOPLE OF- IF THAT PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE. THIS BILL REQUIRES A
CVC TO CONSULT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DURING THE CREATION OF A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. THE BILL ALSO
CLEAR FLY SIX PROJECTS
DEVELOPING IN STATE RAW
MATERIALS AND SUPPLY CHAINS FOR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE RESOURCES
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING FROM
THE CDC'S CLEAN TRANSPORTATION.
PROGRAM THIS BILL REQUIRES A
CVC TO INCLUDE WORKFORCE AND
TRAINING NEEDS IN ITS REGULAR
ASSESSMENT OF RESOURCES AND
REQUIRES TO SEE EASY TO WORK
WITH GROUPS DEVELOPING HIERO
TRAINING PROGRAMS. POLICY
REMISSION TRANSPORTATION HAS
BECOME A MAJOR CALIFORNIA
EXPORT THE STATE IS RELIANT ON
FOREIGN SUPPLY CHAINS FOR
CLEAN. VEHICLES VEHICLE
MATERIALS AND COMPONENTS
CALIFORNIA'S IMPROVE VALLEY.
COULD BE A MAJOR RESOURCE FOR
IN STATE DEVELOPMENT OF LITHIUM
AND SUPPLY CHAINS OF OTHER
IMPORTANT MINERALS TO THE SEND.
WHICH CAN HELP LOWER BATTERY
COSTS TO BRING TRANSPORTATION
JOBS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL SUPPORTS
EFFORTS TO DEVELOP INSIGHTS IN
STATE SUPPLY OF THE RAW
MATERIALS AND COMPONENTS NEEDED
FOR. ELECTRIC VEHICLES BY
MAKING. PROJECTS THAT DEVELOP
THE SUPPLY CHAINS ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING FROM THE CEC'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE WILL ENSURE THAT WE
AS WE GROW INVESTMENTS IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. WE WILL ALSO
GROW IN STATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES PARTICULARLY. IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
THE GREEN ECONOMY IF- THE CHAIR
PERMITS I HAVE A SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT. OF THIS PROJECT
DANIELLE LYNCH'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE. GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR WESSEL.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE ENSURE
THAT MS LYNCH IS ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU META MODERATION OF
MISS LYNCH IS HER LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DANIELLE IN THE AGAIN I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. TOP
REPRESENTS THE FOURTEENTH STATE
CERTIFIED NONPROFIT LOCAL CORDS
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
EACH CAR WORKED WITH YOUNG
ADULTS AGES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. MANY
DON'T HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA ARE HOMELESS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND ALMOST ALL ARE FROM
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
IN SHORT THOSE WERE NOT AT THE
EXACT FIRE. TRADITIONAL THE
TENS AND- THE GIRL AND CORE IS
PROVIDE THE YOUNGER WITH
INDIVIDUAL TOWARDS IT ATTAIN
THAT. WE DO THAT GIVING EACH.
THE OPERA. TO AT HE NEVER HAD
CALLED. AT THE AN ON SITE
CHARTERS WELL. ACT CANCELING
CAREER GUIDANCE JOB PLACEMENT
THE POOR IN OTHER TOP
MANAGEMENT SKILLS. AND COLOR
SHIFT IN SUPPORT AND ROLLING IN
SECONDARY EDUCATION WORK ON
CRITICAL LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECT LEARN THE REAL
CERTIFIED FIELD THEY CAN TAKE
TO THE WORKPLACE. AND GET PAID
WHILE DOING ALL THE THINGS. AND
WE DID IT ALL WITH A PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON WORK THAT SERVES OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT. YOU KNOW THAT THE
STATE HAS AMBITIOUS IN RIGHT TO
FAB GOLD. BUT THE WAY THAT WE
GET THERAPY COOLEY IMPORTANT.
SB FIVE EIGHT NINETY THEM
PORTENT FOR MANY REASONS TO
WHICH I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT. SB
FIVE EIGHT NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE LOCAL COURT THERE AT
THE TABLE WHEN DESIGNING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. WHICH
WE HOPE WILL HAVE IMPACT ON THE
ENTIRE TRANSPORTATION FACTOR
WORKS CITED TO DOUBLE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMISSION TO PROVIDE
A VALUABLE PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. IMAGE
FACTOR CAN BE INCLUSIVE
EQUITABLE AND REAL. SECONDLY AT
THE FIVE EIGHT NINE WOULD
EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY OF
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS FOR FUNDING UNDER THE
PROGRAM. IT WOULD PROVIDE THE
YOUTH. AND YOUNG ADULTS WE WORK
WITH REAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
START GAINING THE SKILLS THEY
NEED TO ENTER INTO THE COVETED
AND GROWING CAREER PATH. IN
THE PROVIDED. I FELL AT OR AT.
NINE I HOPE YOU ALL I TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS LEN.
ALL RIGHT OF MOVING ON WHAT WAS
NO OTHER WITH. PROVIDING TO. IN
SOME. TO HAVE ANYONE THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY
NINE YOU SEEN. FROM ONE TWELVE
SEEN. SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE MODERATOR FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES INSUPPORT
OF SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
FIRST FIND A COMMENTERS NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING SURE
NUMBERS I'M OFTEN SEE A
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF ENERGY SOURCE MIDDLE. ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS ANOTHER WITH THE
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY IN
SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JERRY NUMBERS ALSO
OFTEN BECAUSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
MOBILITY CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER. COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION WILL
LOOK TO THE GALLERY SEE NONE-
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION WE SEE
NONE. SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU MISTER MODERATOR FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT ON THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE OKAY THANK YOU
WE'VE CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I WILL TAKE IT BACK
TO MEMBERS SENATOR NEWMAN. I
THANK YOU MANAGER SENATE HUESO
THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND I
COMMEND YOU IS THOSE- OUR
MEMBERS ARE PROBABLY WHERE THE
BIG BECAUSE OF THE INHERENT
DIFFERENCES IN. EV'S VERSUS
CONVENTIONAL VEHICLES. WE'RE
SEEING A REVOLUTION IN SUPPLY
CHAIN MANAGEMENT AND SO ONE OF
THE GREAT OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IS TO BRING
ASSEMBLY TO OUR STATE BECAUSE
HE VIEWS DON'T REQUIRE SOME OF
THE KIND OF FOUNDRY ANOTHER
KIND OF MATERIAL INTENSIVE
OPERATIONS THAT. INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES USED SO I
THINK IT'S WHOLLY APPROPRIATE.
TO INCORPORATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS A RESOURCE FOR
THE C. T. P. AND I COMMEND YOU
FOR THE BILL AND I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT TODAY IT ALSO HAS TO BE
ADDED. AS A CO AUTHOR ON THE
BILL MOVES FOR THANK YOU. THE
SENATOR NEWMAN'S WITH
HOUSEKEEPING THANK MANAGER JUST
HAVE A WORD OF CAUTION-
BECAUSE- RHETORICAL QUESTION ON
THE DOORMAT CLOCK COMMERCE
CLAUSE. I KNOW THIS ISN'T GOING
TO JUDICIARY BUT YOU KNOW
NORMALLY INTERSTATE COMMERCE
IS. RESERVED TO YOU THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE DORMANT COMMERCE
CLAUSE SORT OF STANDS FOR THIS
IDEA THAT STATES. SHOULD MAKE
RULES THAT IMPEDE INTERSTATE
COMMERCE SO I'M JUST PUTTING
THE ISSUE ABOUT THE RAW
MATERIALS. AND THE COMPONENT
PARTS BEFORE ASSEMBLING FOR ALL
I WANT TO BUILD ZEPCE WE GOT
THAT. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
EMPHASIS OF. THE AND I PLUG ALL
THE- BELLS AND WHISTLES FOR THE
CONSERVATION CORPS IN. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA JUST.
WORD OF CAUTION OF WE DON'T
WANT. WE DON'T WANNA. BE TOO
ENTHUSIASTIC THAT WE MAKE
SOMETHING THAT BECOMES. A
FORCIBLE SERVICE ANDI DON'T
KNOW IF THE- PARTY DOESN'T HAVE
TO RESPOND RIGHT NOW WE GOT A
LOT OF STUFF ON OUR AGENDA SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCCASKILL I
SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP I'LL JUST
SAY- SENATOR WEST WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AS
WELL I THINK WE BOTH HAVE
SIMILAR BILLS. THAT ARE- KIND
OF. WALKING IN PARALLEL SO
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL AS WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE GOMEZ
REYES WHEN I WAS WORKING ON A
SIMILAR BILL TO. REAUTHORIZE A
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
BUT THIS SEEMS. TO BE A GREAT
BILL. AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK ROOMS REMEMBER OF
BRITISH THE CALM WILL-
CONSIDER. YOUR COMMENTS AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND- TO OUR
ARCH. OF MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND YOU KNOW
I'M ALSO INTERESTED IN WORKING
TO SEE HOW WE- CAN MAKE OUR OUR
BILLS- BUT WORK TOGETHER SO-
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY TO CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR WESSEL WHAT
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE CENTER NEWMAN
MOTIONS. OUT SO IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND MISTER CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE DALLAS HI GONZALEZ I BATES.
HI BATES AYE ALLEN. ARCHULETA
HI ARCHULETA HI BETTER WRITE
BETTER HI CORTESE ALL RIGHT
PRETTY EASY AYE DALY HI KELLY
HI DODD AYE DODD AYE MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ HIGH MAN
HI MAN HI NEWMAN HI NEWMAN AYE
RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE NUMBER FIVE NUMBER
I Y. CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I WILL.
FOURTEEN ZERO. FOURTEEN ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR WESSEL NEXT
WE HAVE OUR OWN COMMITTEE
MEMBER SENATOR ARCHULETA
WELCOME. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I
AM SO PROUD AND HONORED TO
PRESENT THE SENATE BILL. SIX
FOUR THREE. SIX SENATE BILL SIX
FOUR THREE TASS THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
CONSULTANT- CONSULTATION WITH
THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
CREATE A WORKING GROUP. TASKED
WITH PREPARING AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC- FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUEL
PRODUCTION NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
VEHICLES. BEFORE GOING ANY
FURTHER I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED ON PAGE
FOR THE ANALYSIS. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BROADEN THIS
ASSESSMENT TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE PROCESS FOR
CREATING HYDROGEN AS WELL AS TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THE
ASSESSMENT. TO LOOK AT OTHER
TRADITIONALLY HARD TO ELECTRIFY
SECTORS LIKE LOCOMOTIVES
MARITIME AND AVIATION. IN
CALIFORNIA THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS THE LEAD AGENCY- IN
WHEN IT COMES TO. HI JIM
ANALYSIS SHOW ASKED THAT WE AT-
COMMISSIONED THEM TO DO THE JOB
MOREOVER THE RESEARCH REPORT IS
WELL EQUIPPED WITH THE TOOLS
AND THE EXPERTISE NEEDED TO
CONVENE THIS WORKING GROUP AND
PREPARE THIS IMPORTANT
ASSESSMENT. HOWEVER THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION IS WHY IS
THIS ASSESSMENT NEEDED.
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS ARE AN
IDEAL ALTERNATIVE FUEL SOLUTION
TO ELECTRIFIED MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY COMMERCIAL VEHICLES. AND
THESE VEHICLES ARE NECESSARY
COMPONENT TO ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY. A QUALITY GOALS
HOWEVER THERE EXISTS A
KNOWLEDGE GAP REGARDING THE
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
REQUIRED FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET
ITS CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS.
STATE AGENCIES ENERGY UTILITIES
AND YOU AND THE LEGISLATOR
LACKS SPECIFIC KNOWLEDGE OF THE
AMOUNT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE HYDROGEN
FUEL PRODUCTION NEEDED TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS.
THIS BILL SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
THREE WILL HELP BRIDGE THE
KNOWLEDGE GAP AND ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO ADEQUATELY PLAN
AND IMPLEMENT HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS AS AN ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
SOURCE. THE ASSESSMENT REQUIRED
IN THIS BILL WILL FOCUS ON
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE DISPENSING AND
DISTRIBUTION EQUIPMENT. STORAGE
EQUIPMENT SUPPORTING HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY CENTER ZHEJIANG
ACROSS HYDROGEN SECTORS THROUGH
THE EXAMPLE OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN PRODUCTION STORAGE AND
DISTRIBUTION. FINALLY TO ENSURE
TIMELY AND CURRENT DATA THE
WORKING GROUP IS REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE THE ASSESSMENT BY
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. WITH THE INFORMATION
FROM THE ASSESSMENT CALIFORNIA
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. ABOUT OUR CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE. ONCE AGAIN I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS I THINK THEY WILL.
MAKE THIS BILL A MUCH BETTER
BILL THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND WITH ME TODAY ON THE
PHONE LINE I HAVE HIM TO SEEN
BOARD PRESIDENT THE WESTERN
STATES HYDROGEN ALLIANCE AND
ROCKSTAND BIKO MADHI EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WESTERN STAGE
HYBRID ALLIANCE BOTH- HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND THEY
WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
OUR TECHNICAL AND THEY'RE READY
TO GO ON NOW THANK YOU MADAM.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE ENSURE
THAT MISTER SUBSCENE IS ON THE
LINE WILL START WITH HIM FIRST.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRED HIM
FIFTEEN IS ACTUALLY NOT
AVAILABLE AT THE MOMENT THIS IS
ROCK FAN BACK MAHONEY I WILL BE
LEADING. FOR HIM WONDERFUL
PLEASE JENNA. I'D YEAH I CAN I
CAN DO MY TESTIMONY- SORRY HAD
TO CUT UP FROM ELEVEN. ALL
RIGHT THIS EXISTING PLEASE
PROCEED. MY APOLOGIES FOR THE
CONFUSION- IN DOLLARS BUT
YOU'RE BATES MEMBERS THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
PAYER TIRELESS WORK TO BRING
EMISSIONS FREE TECHNOLOGY TO
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. MY
NAME IS BEING ON THE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT MANAGER FOR BALLARD
POWER SYSTEMS AND YEARS FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE WESTERN STATE
HYDROGEN ALLIANCE WE ARE I
REALLY WOULDN'T FEEL SO
MANUFACTURERS SEEKING TO
ESTABLISH A FAIR AND OPEN
MARKETPLACE FOR HYDROGEN AT AN
EMISSIONS FREE ENERGY KERRY
ALTERNATIVE. POP UP YOU'LL BE
GREAT EXPANSION. SB SIX FORTY
THREE EMPOWER CARD. IF YOU SEEN
PROPERLY. ASSESS HIGH ALTER IN
THE LONG. GRAY AND BAD UPTURN
FOR THE IF I WERE SUCH A- CAN
BE COST EFFECTIVE. IN BETWEEN.
HUNDRED AND MARK. OR ABSENT
LONG TERM PLANNINGFOR THE
TRANSITION OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY SYSTEM TO ACARBON FREE
ONE. AT THE SAME TIME I HI
AGAIN CONTINUE TO ADVANCE AND
TRUCKING RAIL OPERATOR THE
MARINE SECTORS. OVERLAPPING
NEED. FURTHER IMPROVE HYDROGEN
TEKANAN. FREE AGENCY THE L. NOW
OPERATE DEALS- BUT NEED TO OR
MORE. THREE MORE IN THE PROCESS
OF PURCHASING CELL ELECTRIC
BUSES AND FOURTEEN IN THE FIRST
EIGHTEEN TRANSIT AGENCIES
SUBMITTING THEIR ZERO EMISSION
BUS TRANSITION PLANS. INCLUDE
ARE OPEN TO HILL COLLECTOR
BUTTON. WHICH WILL THEN
CONSTITUTE A QUARTER TO A HALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S TRANSIT POLICE.
I DIDN'T FEEL SO THE
COMMERCIALIZED IN TRANSIT TODAY
AND A TRUCKING WE JUST
COMPLETED A VERY SUCCESSFUL TO
YOUR DEMONSTRATION OF THE CLASS
EIGHT. FUEL CELL DRAYAGE
TRUCKING COMMERCIAL OPERATION
WITH UPS SIDE. FROM LONG BEACH
AND LA. EMPOWER YOUR DRUG
ARRIVING SUMMER THE BORDERLINE
BEACH AND- OF FUEL CELL YOU.
DELIVERY TRUCKS ARE ARRIVING
CHECK FOR THIS SUMMER AS WELL.
ENGINE SEVENTY THE METERING. OF
THE ADVANCE CLEAN REGULAR.
INNOVATIVE CLEAN MIRANDA GREEN
ARE GONNA ASK OUR LOW VOTER
REGULATION. GO RIGHT AHEAD
SURE- SORRY- JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I DO CAN BE KEYSTONE
COMPONENTS OF AN ENERGY SYSTEM
TO SUPPORT PEACEFULLY AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT ALL OPERATIONS
AND ALL OPTIONS BE CONSIDERED
AND THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DEVELOP
ITS HYDROGEN ROADMAP ALONGSIDE
OTHER ADVANCED COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD SO I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS
MATTER I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SASINE OUR NEXT
WILL MOVE OVER TO MS BIG MAMADI
FOR A FROM THE WESTERN STATES
HEADED AN ALLIANCE DO WE HAVE
HER ON THE LINE MODERATOR. YEAH
I'M HERE GOOD MORNING NOT
UNCHECKING HERE AND HE WAS A
MEMBER MY NAME IS NOT AN ATTACK
MAHOGANY. BECKETT AFTER THE- HI
JOHN LINE OPEN AND MISSION. I
THANK YOU FROM THE QUALITY THE
PLANE. ONE HUNDRED. AND MUCH
AND PASS BACK. I MEAN SAID
CLARA IN AND BUTTON HAVE. A
AGUIAR-CURRY UP HAS YOUR
DISCIPLINE. IF I HAD BE
APPLICATION. UNDERSTAND WE ARE
HEY ON HOW I WANT TO BACK AT
AND I. WITH THE I DON'T THINK
YOU THANK YOU VERY. ALRIGHT
WEAKENED OUR TEST AND OF B.
FORTY WERE WILL NUMBER TO THE
GALA SCENE. ONE THE GALLERY
ONE. C. NO WITNESSES AND- THERE
WILL BACK TO THE MY- FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FORTY THREE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND IF YOU WERE TO
SPEAK SUPPORT OF S. SIX FORTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOSH THANK YOU
OPERATOR- GOOD MORNING- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- THREE TO COOK ON
THE HEALTH OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION I PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE WENT
ONLINE ARE COMMON WITH THOSE
MADE BY A ACTION IN FROM
BALLARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WILL MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE GIVE ANYONE
REGISTERED AT THIS TIME BUT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND- INQUIRE IF
THERE ANY. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION SB SIX
FORTY THREE PLEASE MADAM
MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX FORTY THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
OKAY. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX FORTY THREE PLEASE.
COMMUNITY YES. YEAH THIS IS
STEPHEN ROSENBAUM ARE
REPRESENTING A THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY- WE'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE THE DEFINITION OF
HYDROGEN AS BEING UP REGULATED
COULD BE PRODUCED USING
RENEWABLE ENERGY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FORTY
THREE PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TME THANK YOU MODERATE
RAIDERS WE'VE CONCLUDED SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WE'LL TAKE THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS TO
BE SEE ANY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR NEWMAN. I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND SOONER OR LATER
ON THIS BILL- DID I THINK IT IS
SMART TO LOOK AT HIGHS AND AS-
A PARALLEL PATH TOWARD CLEAN
ENERGY IN A- DIED BE GRATEFUL
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR THANKS.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I ALSO- I THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT WAY TO JUST LOOK
AT THE ALTERNATIVES I THINK
THAT- FOCUSING ON HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS AS WELL JUST GOOD SO I
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE SPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
SPECTER. I THINK THE AUTHORED
ME THESE COMING SAID IN A
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE- BUT- I'M
MOST EXCITED ABOUT HI JIM FOR
SOME OF THESE USERS WE TALKED
ABOUT FOR THE HEAVY DUTY.
TRUCKING RATHER THAN SAY THE
LIGHT DUTY AND- ENCOURAGE A
GREEN SOURCES AS WELL THANKS.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER I
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR TO WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS CENTERSTHANK YOU SO
MUCH I THINK WE ARE. AT THE
DOORSTEP OF NEW ENERGY. A NEW
WAVE OF MAKING SURE OUR
HIGHWAYS ARE CLEANER THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WORKING
TOGETHER AND THIS WORKING.
GROUP THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
GOING TO BRING IN PRODUCTION
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE
FUELING RETAIL IT'S GOING TO
BRING IT TOGETHER AND SO WE
WILL ALL KNOW. TOTALLY HOW THIS
IS GOING TO WORK IN THE FUTURE.
AND AGAIN ONCE AGAIN WE'LL HAVE
THE ANSWERS BUT TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AROUND THE CORNER SO WE
CAN GO FORWARD INTO THE FUTURE.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHER LET US TO DO WE
HAVE A MOTION SB SIX FORTY
THREE SENATOR NEWMAN. MAKES THE
MOTION MISTER CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE DALLAS
HI GONZALEZ HI BATES. ALAN
PARTULA ARCHULETA HI BAKER HI
BAKER HI CORTESE CORTESE I.
DALI HI KELLY HI DOT HI DODD
AYE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ AYE
LENDERS AYE MIN ALL RIGHT MAN
HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HIGH
RUBIO HI RUBIO HI SKINNER.
NUMBER MICHALSKI BY KELSEY HIGH
WILK. BATES IS AN AYE BATES HI.
TOKYO GREAT THANK YOU CENTER TO
LET IT LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THE COMMISSION MANAGER THANK
YOU WELCOME SENATOR THE RUSSELL
SHE'S HERE TO PRESENT SB. SIX
SEVENTY FOUR. OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING. I GET
STARTED YES PLEASE OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I WANNA THANK YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STUFF FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF THE
ANALYSIS TO EXPLICITLY EXEMPT
CONTRACTS WITH DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS. I REVIEW THE
CONSIDERATIONS AND ANALYSIS AND
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK- TO
ADDRESS EACH OF THESE POINTS WE
HAVE BEEN ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND AS A RESULT SB
SIX SEVEN FOUR HAS NO CURRENT
KNOWN OPPOSITION WELL MY OFFICE
WILL CONTINUE TO. MEET WITH
TRANSIT AGENCIES WE HAVE
SEVERAL IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING. SCHEDULED AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR WILL SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF EQUITABLE HIGH
QUALITY TRANSPORTATION AND
RELATED MANUFACTURING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS IN OUR
STATE THE GOVERNOR JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSES FOUR AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS AN
EQUITABLE RECOVERY FOR
BUSINESSES. AND SUSTAINABLE JOB
CREATION AND A ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF THE TRANSITION TO
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. INCLUDE
GOOD PAYING JOBS QUALITY JOBS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY LEFT OUT. THIS
BILL FOCUSES ON CREATING
QUALITY CLIMATE RESILIENT JOBS
WITH OUR TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS
LAST YEAR IS AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ACCORDING CALL PUTTING
CALIFORNIA ON THE HIGH ROAD A
JOBS AND CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
FOR TWENTY THIRTY IDENTIFY
GOODS MOVEMENT AND MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE AS THE BIGGEST SINGLE
CONTRIBUTOR OF POLLUTION. BUT
IT ALSO SAYS QUOTE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM UNDERPINS OUR ECONOMY
THE FREIGHT SYSTEM MOVES
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF GOODS
EACH YEAR SUPPORTING NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF THE STATE ECONOMY AND
MORE THAN FIVE MILLION JOBS.
THIS IS WHY PARTNERSHIPS WITH
BUSINESS CAN LEAD TO PROSPERITY
FOR EVERYONE AND THE
SUSTAINABLE HEALTHY FUTURE FOR
OUR STATE SIX SEVENTY FOUR
WOULD ENACT THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
PLAN TO CREATE A CLEAR
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMPANIES WHO
BENEFIT FROM PUBLICLY FUNDED
TRANSPORTATION CONTRACTS. AND
SUBSIDIES WITH CLEAR AND
TRANSPARENT ABOUT COMMITMENTS-
THE JOB PLAN IS A COMPONENT OF
AN APPLICATION THAT WOULD BE
SUBMITTED BY APPLICANTS FOR
COVERED PUBLIC CONTRACTS THAT
SPECIFY. THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF
JOBS PROPOSED WAGES PROPOSED
BENEFITS INVESTMENT IN TRAINING
AND TARGETED HIRING PLANS FOR
DISPLACED WORKERS AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED. THE JOB PLAN
COMPONENT WILL NOT REQUIRE ANY
NEW MINIMUM COMMITMENTS OTHER
THAN THOSE ALREADY REQUIRED. BY
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAWS.
WE WOULD SIMPLY ADD ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION TO APPLICANTS THE
PLAN WILL NOT BE WAIT HIGHER
THAN OTHER SECTIONS. PRESIDENT
BY AND HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT
PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD CREATE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON CLIMATE
IMPLEMENTS FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN FEDERAL POLICY. A PAIRING OF
THE URGENT ISSUES OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS WITH THE CREATION
OF NEW GOOD JOBS FOR WORKERS
AND PEOPLE IN HEAVILY POLLUTED
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE AN
OPORTUNITY TO MEET THE GOALS
OF OUR OWN CALIFORNIA FUTURE
WORK COMMISSION MADE UP OF
BUSINESSES COMMUNITY AND LABOR.
TO HELP CREATE THOSE LONG TERM
ECONOMIC GROWTH THIS IS A
MECHANISM TO ACHIEVE OUR BOLD
AND URGENT VILLAGE IS NOT IN-
VISION IS NOT ENOUGH TO SAY WE
WANT TO CREATE GOOD JOBS WE
NEED CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR
COMMITMENTS TO JOB CREATION AND
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION. BUT WE WILL MOVE
STATE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF THESE
HIGH QUALITY JOBS. AND ENSURE
PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO GIVE THESE
JOBS TO MEN AND WOMEN AND ALL
COMMUNITIES TODAY WE HAVE
MELANIE JAMILA PRASAD WITH OUR
JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA AS THE KEY
WITNESS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU A SENATOR THAT ALSO-
WILL GO AHEAD AND- ASK IF SHE
IS ON THE- LINE MET MODERATOR
DO YOU HAVE MELANIE JIMMY LEE.
ON THE LINE PLEASE. MODERATOR.
DO WE HAVE MELANIE JIMMY LEE ON
THE LINE. OKAY I'LL ASK ONE
MORE TIME MODERATOR DO HAVE
MELANIE JOIN ME LIVE ON THE
LINE. NO. OKAY LET'S FIRST GO
TO OUR FIGURING OUT THE
TECHNICAL- ISSUES HERE LET'S GO
TO ANYBODY IN THE GALLERY FOR
SUPPORT SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR C.
NINE. SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR
SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. WE
SEE NONE. AND WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO THE LINE TO SEE IF WE
CAN HEAR OUR MODERATOR AGAIN.
GIVE US ONE MOMENT THANK YOU
SENATOR TO RUSSELL.
OKAY CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
MELANIE JIMMY LEE ON THE LINE
PLEASE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR. IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE MELANIE IS ON THE LINE SHE
HAD LAPTOP AND SHE'S NOT BACK
ON YET. OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED WITH ADDITIONAL
WITNESS- ADDITIONAL- SUPPORTERS
FOR SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT. OKAY IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. HEY WE WILL GO
TOWARD FIRST LINE OF ONE OLD
THREE LINE IS OPEN. THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE WILL GO
TO OUR NEXT LINE OF SIXTY FOUR.
THE LINE IS NOW OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE FLOCKS
ON BEHALF ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION AND THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION
OF LABOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK HERE NOW WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HANDED PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS CHRIS
OCULUS ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THE
NEXT LINE IS THE ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. UNBRANDED
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU-
THANK YOU NEXT THE NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM A LINE OF ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WOULD SUGGEST YOU KNOW WHAT THE
UNITED AUTO WORKERS REGION
EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NOW TO THE LOCAL LINE OF
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MIKE MADIGAN
OF THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. CALIFORNIA STATE I
COULD COUNSEL IN THE WESTERN
CITY COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR. RIGHT I'M- THANK
YOU LOW VOTER LINE NUMBER ONE
OWN
REPAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR THE
LOCAL I. NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
CANADIAN MY NAME IS MELANIE
PRESS FIVE AND I WOULD CALL THE
EARLY AND THEY DID THAT. THE
PART WITNESSES BUT AND I WOULD
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES CALL EIGHT AND
LIKE TO GET MY MONEY NOW
ABSOLUTELY PLEASE GO. AHEAD
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. YEAH
NINE AM SHARE MEMBERS OF AND
TAKEN IT'S NOT NINE I MEAN LIKE
HOW. DIRECTOR AND JOB WITH
AMERICA AND MELANIE SORRY WE
CAN HEAR YOU IF YOU CAN JUST-
GET A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE MIKE
IF YOU IF YOU WILL. THANK YOU
HEAR ME NOW MUCH BETTER THANK
YOU. AND SO I THINK THAT AND
THE CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR OF JOBS
WITH AMERICA AND NATIONAL
STRATEGIC RESEARCH AND POLICY
CENTER DEDICATED TO ENSURING
THAT PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE SPENT
IN A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES THE
PUBLIC AT THE I'M HERE TODAY TO
VOICE STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
PLAN. NINETEEN ABOUT HOW WE
INVEST PUBLIC DOLLARS WE CAN
INVEST IN CLIMATE STATE
TRANSPORTATION. EATING GOOD
MIDDLE CLASS CAREER PATHWAYS
BUT COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THEM
THE MOST. I MEAN SOME RADICAL
NEW THEORETICAL SOLUTION. ONE
THAT COMES WITH A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF SUCCESS ACROSS THE
LAST DECADE. THE CALIFORNIA JOB
PLAN IS THE CULMINATION OF
LEARNING FROM THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE OF THE U. S. EMPLOYMENT
BROWN WITH FIRST HIGHLIGHTED IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN BY THE LOS
ANGELES METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. AND
HAS SINCE BEEN USED BY AGENCIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY INCLUDING IN
NEW YORK CITY CHICAGO ATLANTA
BOSTON AND MINNEAPOLIS ST PAUL
TO CREATE THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. PLEASE
CONTACT. ARE NOT UNIQUE TO THE
U. S. EMPLOYMENT PLAN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA JOB PLAN IN GOOD JOB
POLICIES THAT REQUIRE ALMOST
IDENTICAL COMMITMENT. EXISTS
ACROSS SECTORS AND ACROSS
CONTRACT TYPE. MOLYNEUX'S OF
ALL AGENCIES HAVE FEDERAL ONE.
OTHER EXAMPLES INCLUDE CAPTAIN
PETE CHANGE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS CO THAT NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM AND
FINANCIAL A GRAND AND
REPRESENTATIVES BACKROOM OF
LOCAL HIRE LOCAL. THE RUN PILOT
WE STUDIED THE DATA AND WE KNOW
THAT THESE POLICIES WORK. WELL
ONE MILLION FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS DON'T
HAVE TIME TO WAIT EVEN MORE
PILOTS EVEN MORE STUDIES AND
EVEN MORE RESEARCH. SPEND TIME
IS NOW FOR STRONG DECISIVE
LEADERSHIP. EVERYONE ACROSS THE
GLOBE HAD SUFFERED THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HOWEVER LONG
TERM EFFECTS WILL BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CARRIED BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN VULNERABLE TO
RISING UNEMPLOYMENT. THE
DRAMATICALLY DENIED ACCESS TO
GENERATION ALLOW UNFETTERED
FROM LACK OF ACCESS TO QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE THANK YOU MELANIE
IF WE CAN RETURN YOU TO WRAP UP
BY I APOLOGIZE. ABSOLUTELY A
RETURN TO A NEW COVERAGE WE
MUST FOR EQUITY CENTERED
SOLUTIONS THAT RECOGNIZE AND
ADDRESS THE DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN ALL CALIFORNIANS WILL
HAVE A BRIGHTER TOMORROW. TODAY
I STAND WITH OVER TWENTY
COMMUNITY LABOR AND EVEN
INDUSTRY ORGANIZATIONS AND ZERO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR MODERATOR
CAN BE PLEASE CONTINUE ON WITH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
FOUR SUPPORT SB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NONE IN THE GALLERY. ON ROUTE
MOVED TO RIP ROOM ONE TWELVE
NONE THERE- WILL GO BACK TO
MODERATOR FOR. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE. COPYRIGHT
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVENTY
POINT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT
HERE. OKAY AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WOULD CONCLUDE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBERS
FOR DISCUSSION DO WE HAVE ANY
COP COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS. SENATOR ARCHULETA YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO COMPLIMENT- A SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT I'M WORKING WITH SO MANY
ENTITIES IN REFERENCE TO
HYDROGEN. IN THE FUTURE OF
HYDROGEN AND THE WORK FORCE
IT'S GOING TO BE INVOLVED THE
NUMBER OF JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
INVOLVED IN A LOT TIED IN
TOGETHER WITH HIS BILL. THAT
ISSUES PUT ON THE TABLE SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR SO I
THINK IT'S A WAY OF COMBINING
THE WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
HYDROGEN THE ENERGY AND ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT GOOD JOBS ARE
CREATED AND EVERYONE'S INCLUDED
IN GIVEN THAT OPPORTUNITY. AND
I URGE AND I BOUGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA I SEE NO
OTHER MIKES UP SENATOR DRAWS I
JUST WNNA SAY THANK YOU AS
WELL I KNOW- YOU'RE COMMITTED
TO THIS AND I KNOW IT'S
CONTINUING TO BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT- COMPLETELY-
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IN THIS SPACE AND I LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU AS WELL
ON. ON THIS BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE VOTE AND AGAIN
APPRECIATION TO YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND YOUR COMMITTEE. UP FOR ALL
THE WORK THA THEY CONTINUE TO
DO WITH US IT'S BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU SENATOR TO
RUSSELL. ALRIGHT SO DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR
MOTION- CHIU LETTER GREAT
MISTER CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. QUESTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ HI BATES. ALLEN WHAT'S
A LETTER HI BUDGET LETTER HI
BAKER. CORTESE ALL RIGHT
CORTESE I DOLLY. DOT HI DODD
AYE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MAN FIVE
MIN HI NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE NUMBER. MY CASKET
HI KELSEY I WILK. NINE ZERO
NINE ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR TO
RUSSELL THANK YOU MIND SHARING
THANK YOU MEMBERS RATE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO A LITTLE
BIT OUT OF ORDER NOW I BELIEVE
WE DO HAVE SENATOR STERN WHO'S
JOINED US REMOTELY. MADAM
CHAIR. THERE YOU ARE WONDERFUL
THANK YOU AND WELCOME SENATOR
STERN- YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT
ON SB FIVE FIVE ONE GO GO RIGHT
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE- WITH THE BILL
FILE ORDER TIMING- REMOTE
SHARING AND PRESENTING AS WE
SPEAK SO. THANKS FOR. I'M YOUR
EFFORTS AND YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE AREA OF TRANSPORTATION
SUSTAINABILITY THIS YEAR AND
ESPECIALLY TO YOUR COMMITTEES
WORK- ON THIS LEGISLATION. I'M
HOPING THAT- THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKING HERE
TODAY I WHICH I MEAN EXCEPT-
ALL THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
YOU SEE THEM ON THAT PAGE FOR
YOUR ANALYSIS- HOPEFULLY SETTLE
SOME OF THE ISSUES AROUND- THE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRALITY OF THIS
FRAMEWORK AND SOME OF THE
ONGOING DEBATES I KNOW THAT.
WE'RE HAVING IS THE SENATE
RIGHT NOW- IN TERMS OF THE
VIABILITY THE VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGIES IN TURKEY IN TERMS
OF ACHIEVING ZERO EMISSIONS
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE. AND
MAKING CLEAR THAT- THIS
LEGISLATION- AND THE AUTHORITY
THAT WE WOULD ESTABLISH IN THIS
LEGISLATION. WOULD ALSO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR INTER
IMPLEMENTING OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO ACHIEVE THAT
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE SEVEN GOAL-
YEAH FROM- FROM TWENTY TWENTY
AND THAT'S A STANDARD THAT
INCLUDES BOTH HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL VEHICLES AS WELL AS-
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. BUT THE
THRUST OF THIS LEGISLATION IS
REALLY DIFFICULT GAP AROUND
ELECTRIC VEHICLE-
INFRASTRUCTURE- DEVELOPING
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS GAPS
THAT CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE A
CENTRAL AUTHORITY WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE
SENIOR LEADERSHIP AT A TIME
WHEN THE STATE'S. HOPEFULLY
GOING TO BE INVESTING. BILLIONS
IF NOT TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS- IN THIS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE VEHICLES AND-
OTHER RELATED WORK AT THE NEEDS
TO HAPPEN TO REALIZE. FUTURE
THAT GOES BEYOND THE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE AT THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IT'S ARE
PRETTY CRIME IT'S IN IS THIS
STATE YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
MEETING LEGISLATION AND
LEGISLATORS AND- YOU KNOW-
INCREDIBLE PRESERVATION OF
HABITAT. IN CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS BUT THE FACT. IS WE ARE
THE LARGEST WORLDS LOOK
TROLLING AND CAN. BESIDES THE
U. AND SHE- WORDS IF THEY'RE
NOT JUST NAY HONOR. TROLLING
CONSUMPTION WITH THE AMOUNT.
AND THAT HAS GOT TO BE. IF YOU
WANT TO DO IT I MEAN GOT A FOR
DOOR INDUSTRY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EVERYONE IS INVOLVED- TO GET
THINGS DONE HERE SO WE HOPE
THIS IS ELECTRIC VEHICLE
AUTHORITY WILL HELP REALIZE THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION- BUILT ON THE
CURRENT- THAT LEFT. FULL I WILL
CALL YOU FIVE DOLLARS IS NOT
NEAR ENOUGH- BUT YOU ALSO.
ALIGNED WITH THE JOBS. AND
WHERE THE PRESIDENT'S PROPOSAL
IS TAKING US- WHICH CURRENTLY
INCLUDES- I THINK SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO STATES- AND
TWELVE STATES SO FAR ALSO
JOINED OUR STATE. IN A CALLING
ON THE PRESIDENT TO HELP ALIGN
WITH OURS YOUR MISSION VEHICLE
GOAL SO. YOU KNOW I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE A MAKER WE'RE NOT
JUST- A TAKER IN THE STATE WHEN
IT COMES ELECTRIC VEHICLES I
THINK WE CAN DO ALL THE WAY
FROM THE LIVE GAME ITSELF. ALL
THE WAY TO THE VEHICLE IN TERMS
OF MANUFACTURING AND JOB
CREATION SO WE GOT BIG
POTENTIAL HERE FOR TRANSCENDING
CHANGE THAT TO ME WILL ACTUALLY
SOLVE. THE MIDDLE CLASSES
ENERGY TRAP NOT JUST SOLVE.
POLLUTION PROBLEMS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES LIVING ON THE FRONT
LINES AND NOT JUST- DEPLOYED
TEST LIST FOR- FOLKS WHO CAN
AFFORD THEM RIGHT NOW BUT IT
ACTUALLY SOLVES. THE BIGGEST
EXPENSE IN THE MIDDLE CLASS
BUDGET IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
NOT FOOD AND NOT HEALTH CARE
IT'S THEIR TRANSPORTATION. IF
YOU CAN FILL UP YOUR CAR FOR
THIRTY THE PRICE AT THE PLUGGED
IN AT THE PUMP. YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA TRANSFORM THIS ECONOMY SO
WITH THAT IN MIND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN AND I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE ONE ONE
OF WHICH IS MATT PETERSON WITH
THE L. A. CLEANTECH INCUBATOR
HE'S ON THE LINE- MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE ENSURE. THAT MR
PETERSON IS ON THE LINE FIRST.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S A GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU HERE TODAY. SURE WE
THINK IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TOLD ME BILL
MONTHLY- SHIP. ON CLIMATE
ACTION BERMEL JUSTICE AND
GROWING THE GREEN ECONOMY.
CREATING OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERYONE- AMERICAN. MISTER
PETERSON. I THINK WE MAY HAVE
LOST YOU MODERATOR IS MISTER
PETERSON ON THE LINE. OKAY
WE'LL GIVE IT ONE MOMENT.
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE
THUNDERSTORMS.
OKAY MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE MISTER PETERSON ON
THE LINE.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
MODERATOR SITUATION SO WE'LL
GIVE THIS ONE MOMENT.
OKAY
MEMBERS WILL TAKE ABOUT A FEW
MINUTE RECESS WHILE WE FIGURE
OUT THE TECHNICAL ISSUES AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK THANK YOU.
TO THE TEAM IN SENATE CHAMBERS
FOR GETTING ON IT WE APPRECIATE
IT. ALL RIGHT WE WILL CONTINUE
ON WITH SENATOR STERN'S BILL SB
FIVE FIVE ONE WE WERE IN THE
MIDST OF. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
FOR MR MATT PETERSON ELLIE
CLEANTECH INCUBATOR. MISTER
PETERSON MODERATOR DO HAVE
MISTER PETERSON ON THE LINE
PLEASE. YES MISTER PETERSON
FINEST OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I GET THE BEST OF MONEY
MR THE SENATE THIS YOU JUST. I
THANK YOU FOR- GIG WE CAN BE US-
BECAUSE EVERYTHING- WE'RE PROUD
WORK WITH SENATOR STERN AND
WHAT WE IS NOT PERTINENT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
ON CLIMATE ACTION BERMAN THE
JUSTICE AND GROWING THE GREEN
ECONOMY AND THE GREAT JOB THAT
COULD COME FROM. MY
ORGANIZATION CONVENES THE
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
PARTNERSHIP WHICH IS UNIQUE
RESULT. THAT PUBLIC PRIVATE
COLLABORATION SIX CELERY. D.
PRODUCTIONS IN CLIMATE AND AIR
POLLUTION BY THE TIME THE WORLD
RISE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY IN
OLYMPIC AND- PARALYMPIC GAMES.
THE OTHER WITH OUR MEMBERS- IN
THIS COALITION WE SET AN
AMBITIOUS REGIONAL SET TARGETS
WEEK LEGAL CREDIT GLIDE PATH TO
THE STATE'S GOALS FOR EXAMPLE
WORK AND WORKING DISCIPLINE
CHURCH 30% OF ALL THE LIKE THE
CARS ON THE ROAD IN L. A.
COUNTY ARE ELECTRIC BY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. AND THAT 40% OF
ALL THE CURRENTLY DIESEL
TRUCKS- TRADE STRUCTURE GONNA
BE ZERO EMISSIONS BY THAT SAME
YEAR. BUT THESE CONDITION YEAH
TERRIBLE CAR GIPSON MIND. AND
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS IN THE
PARTNERSHIP. DEVELOP VEHICLE
READY CONCEPT ENSURE WE HAVE.
THE LEVEL OF LEADERSHIP
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FINANCING
TOOLS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THIS
ECONOMY WIDE TRANSFORMATION.
SAYS THEIR MISSION ABOUT FUTURE
THE CALIFORNIA SET AS A GOAL. I
NEED THIRTY WOULD BUILD ON THE
WORK EACH THE AGENCIES INVOLVED
IN THE SPACE. WHETHER IT'S CARP
C. C. GO BEEN ALL INCREDIBLE
PARTS OF THE STATE BY PROVIDING
INCREASED LEVEL OF FOCUS AND
EFFORT. COORDINATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY LED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. MAJORITY
WOULD DO THREE THINGS FIRST IT
WOULD PROVIDE SENIOR LADERSHIP
STRATEGIC PLANNING AN EXPANDED
PARTNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES TO
COMPLEMENT THE WORK OF STATE
AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. INCLUDING THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ANOTHER LAKE RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW TO
BETTER WORK WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. AS WELL AS LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
SECOND WOULD PROVIDE THE
FUNDING AND FINANCING TOOLS TO
SUPPORT THESE DEPLOYMENT
EFFORTS BRINGING PRIVATE
CAPITAL TO THE TABLE AND
HELPING UNLOCK THOSE RESOURCES.
WE KNOW AB EIGHT NEED TO BE RE
UP RIGHT NOW TO GALLERY G. W.
DOBSON. AND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT BE PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT. CLEAN THAT TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AS YOU'VE LAID OUT IN
YOUR LEGISLATION MADAM CHAIR.
WE APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS CHAIR OF COURSE
WITH YOUR LEGISLATION WE THINK
IT'S A COMPLIMENTARY. AT THE
CRITICAL DOWN PAYMENT THESE
DOLLARS- PLAN WHICH WE NEED TO
IDENTIFY OTHER FUNDING AND
FINANCING TOOLS. TO REALLY SEE
HOW WE CAN. FILL THE GAPS WHERE
WE SEE THEM- AS WELL AS ENSURE
THE SOME OF THE WHOLE IS
GREATER THAN ITS PARTS WITH THE
FUNDING RESOURCES THAT WE DO
INSURE- PLACE. AND FINALLY. AND
IMPORTANTLY THE V. THIRTY WOULD
PARKSIDE. ACROSS ALL THESE
INVESTMENTS IMPLEMENTATION AND
DEPLOYMENTS AS WELL AS TRY FOR
MY BRIDGE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
WE NEED. IN THIS INCREDIBLE
TRANSIT TRANSITION AND
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR ECONOMY.
HERE WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
AND WE NEED THE RESOURCES TO
GET THERE. TODAY LESS THAN 10%
THE CARS BEING SOLD CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC WE NEED TO GET A
HUNDRED PERCENT. BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. WE NEED A 100% OF
DRAYAGE TRUCKS TO BE ZERO
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AS WELL AS AN INCREASING NUMBER
OF OTHER TRUCKS. AND BUSES
ACROSS THE STATE. GOLD
COMPORTMENT THE GERMANS TRANS
REQUIRE SOMEBODY'S SOLELY.
ACCOUNTABLE THE GOVERNOR TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR MAKING IT HAPPEN
IN THE FAIREST. AND MOST
EFFICIENT WAY POSSIBLE. HE'STO
BE JOINED BY SEVENTY
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTED THIS
BILL INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY LEADERS START UPS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS PUBLIC HEALTH.
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS ACADEMIA
AND MORE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER PETERSON AND WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE EARLIER
INCONVENIENCE BUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN THIS.
NEXT WE HAVE- MS BROWNING UP
BUT THE- BUT THE EXAMPLES FROM
PICK UP THE QUEMA BEAUTIFUL IN
SUPPORT AS WELL. MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE MISSED BY THE EXAMPLES
ON THE LINE. YES EVERYONE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS THAT ONLY GOT BY THE
EXAMPLE I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CUENTA PUPIL WE ARE
GRASSROOTS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS SERVING
THE NORTH SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
ACTITUDES ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IS KEY TO OUR BROADER
MISSION OF HELPING OUR
COMMUNITY BE HEALTHIER AND ABLE
TO THRIVE WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
PROUD TO BE PARTNERING WITH
LEAKY TO BRING CLEAN RELIABLE
AND EXCEPT FOR THE CRITICAL
OPTIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY.
TOGETHER WE'RE IMPLEMENTING A
CRUSHER WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A CAR
SHARING PROGRAMCALLED QUIT MY
LECTURE SHARE WHICH IS PROOF
PROVING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
ASSET TO THE COMMUNITY
PROVIDING ELECTRIC VEHICLES FOR
RUNNING ERRANDS OR MAKING IT TO
A MEDICAL APPOINTMENT OR
ANYTHING THAT IS NEEDED FOR
FAMILY- ESPECIALLY NOW DURING
THE CALL THAT TIME. WHAT
EXCITED TO HAVE THIS PROGRAM IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE INVESTMENT
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN MADE WE
STILL NEED MORE AND WE WANT TO
SEE MORE COMMUNITIES LIKE OURS
GAINING ACCESS TO AND
BENEFITING. FROM ZERO EMISSIONS
TRANSITION. BUT WE ARE PLEASED
SUPPORT THE- OF CAL. NEXT
VEHICLE A THIRTY. TO INSURE
THAT CAN. HAS A COORDINATED
STATEMENTS. TO LET THAT ANTI
THE PERSON. TO THE EVEN INPUT
NEEDS AND FROM MY- ARE
PRIORITIZE IN THE- ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. WHICH
SUPPORT AS FIVE FIVE POINT I
WAS THE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR- THANK YOU VERY. OKAY
THANK YOU MISSED THE EXAMPLES
WE YOUR TEST IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE ONE THANK YOU- I WILL
GOOD NEXT GO TO THE GALLERY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THERE THERE ARE NONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE WE SEE NONE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FIVE ONE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE FIVE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CAPPING LANDS REPRESENTING
CLARK IN AMERICA YOU CAN'T WAIT
CONSUMER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR
STERN'S SB FIVE FIFTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMONPLACE
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX. MY
APOLOGIES NINE ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BEEN SUPPORT MUCH OF
WHAT THE CLIMATE CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ALLOWED
I WOULD ADEQUATE VITAMIN GROUP
ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA AND EAST BAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY IN THE PARK
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU WILL BERIKUT
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF. I'M
SORRY NINE THIRTY SEVEN MAYBE
WE HAVE YOUR REPEAT WE COULD
BARELY HEAR YOU. I'M SORRY
WE'LL BE RIGHT WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DILLON JACK ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. MY ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PHIL MURPHY ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NOR COUNSEL CAL
CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT. MY NAME
ONE I'M SORRY ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING ERIC MARC WHAT
THE PORT OF LA YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FURTHER PROOF JERRY HARMER
COULD ALTERNATIVES WE'RE IN
SUPPORT- NINE ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAMBERS
HOW TRITON WHICH I'M PRESIDENT
FOURTEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
BORROWER PRESS ONE OR- AND ALSO
LIKE REGENCY FOR AN HOUR THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARGARET CLUTCHING ON BEHALF OF
CRUZ WE'RE IN SUPPORT AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON AMENDMENTS. NINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ROD BREWER FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
CURRENT SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
FIVE ONE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MOVING ON TO MINE ONE
FIFTY THREE. ONE ONE FIFTY
THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ANASTASIA CONSEQUENT CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF AN AUDI
OFAMERICA- A COMMUNIQUE IN
SUPPORT OF- SB FIVE FIVE ONE.
ONE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AT NINETY PROVIDE ON
BEHALF OF JOBS IN AMERICA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FIVE ONE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL MOVE
ON TO. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FIVE ONE WE DO NOT HAVE
OR- LEAD WITNESS REGISTERED- WE
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION WE'LL GO BACK TO
MODERATOR FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FIVE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
THE OPPOSITION Q. FOR SB FIVE
FIVE ALL. RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE CONCLUDED SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE FIVE
ONE WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR CHIRLA.
DISTRICT MANAGER QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR PLEASE OKAY SAID
ARCHULETA MISSED SENATOR STERN
WOULD YOU. LIKE TO TAKE A
QUESTION FROM SEN ARCHULETA
ABSOLUTELY YES SENATOR THANK
YOU- IT'S A GREAT BILL I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT IT. I WAS
HOPING THAT YOU MIGHT AENDED
TO INCLUDE THE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES- WHICH ARE
OBVIOUSLY HYDROGEN SO JUST BY
INCLUDING THAT IT OPENS THE
DOOR. WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE THINK
ABOUT FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND I THINK WE
DISCUSSED IT. ON THE- OF LAST
THE COMMITTEE MEETING THAT WE
HAD YOU HAD AGREED TO DO THAT I
JUST DIDN'T SEE IT HERE. SO I
THINK THERE'S STILL TIME TO DO
IT SO IF YOU CAN INCLUDE THAT I
REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE. A
MADAM CHAIR YES ABSOLUTELY
SENATE-DISTRICT OKAY RESPONSE
OKAY THANK YOU- YEAH AND THANK
YOU CENTER JEWELERS. IN MY
OPENING COMMENTS. THAT WAS MY
IT WAS ARE TEMPTED- NOT BEING
TWO TECHNOLOGIES TO CANCER TO
ELEVATING SAY HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL OVER ANYTHING ELSE BUT BY
REFERRING TO THAT EXECUTIVE FOR
ABOUT THE TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
SEVEN GOAL WHICH DOES PUT.
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL AS VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT
AS SORT OF A CENTERPIECE OF
THAT. THAT WAS MY ATTEMPTED TO
SPEAK TO- YOUR- SOME OF THE
ISSUES YOU RAISED IN YOUR YOUR
EXCELLENT LEADERSHIP BY THE WAY
ON A WHAT I SEE IS IT REALLY A
COMPANION MEASURE I THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW GETTING GETTING THE
HYDROGEN CITED IT CLEANED UP
AND DEPLOYED AND- AND THAT IS
COST EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE BE
IMPORTANT BUT I JUST DON'T WANT
TO BE TOO HEAVY IT ABOUT-
TESTIFYING MORE. JUSTICE
INTEGRATED OVERALL FRAMEWORK IT
SHOULD INCLUDE ALL SO HOPEFULLY
ALIGNS WITH YOUR DEFINITION OF.
A STEP ON THAT. MAYBE CARE.
ANYWAY I'M TOTALLY COMMITTED TO
WORKING TO IF YOU HAVE THE
PURPOSE FOR TODAY. THANK VERY
MUCH THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND STERN NEXT WE'VE
SENATOR MAN. NO SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT OWNED IT
FOR MANY REASONS BUT-
PERSONALITY COMMIT THE OTHER
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
JUST SAW IT THINK THE FUTURE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES REALLY
DEPENDS ON BEING A STRATEGIC
ABOUT THE FUTURE AND I THINK
JUST HAVING THIS CENTRALIZED
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC VEHICLE
THIRTY WILL HELP COORDINATE ALL
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR SPECIFICALLY SPOKE AT
THE CALL THAT THE MIDDLE CLASS.
TRAP BUT I FEEL IT'S THE MIDDLE
CLASS RELUCTANCE AND JUST
HAVING A PLAN TO REPEAT YOU
KNOW FOCUS ON THE WORK FORCE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS NEEDED
I THINK THAT THAT WOULD HELP
JUST BRING CALIFORNIANS ALONG
ESPECIALLY THAT MIDDLE CLASS
THAT CONTINUES TO HAVE THAT
HESITANCY BUT I WANT TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THINKING. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO I SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
SENATOR STERN I'D ALSO LIKE TO
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT IT
ABSOLUTELY ALIGNS WITH A LOT OF
THE GOALS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE- WOULD ALSO LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU I KNOW IT COMPLIMENTS
THE BILL THAT I WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT NEXT- WHICH IS- A
REGARDING THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND ALL
OF THESE- GOAL CERTAINLY ALIGNS
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. TO
THAT WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU- TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THIS SOUTH
PERSONNEL LA IN SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY. FOR HER PARTNER SHE-
AND HER FOCUS HERE THAT THIS
ISN'T JUST ABOUT- HARD TO REACH
TECHNOLOGY THIS IS BACK VERY
PRACTICAL WORK- ME. IN SERVING
ALL THE PRIVATE. WHO PROPEL
THEMSELVES. HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF MILES SUPER
COMMUTERS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
IF WE CAN GET. ALL THE IF THE
MANUFACTURERS TO THE JOB
CENTRE. THE DRIVERS THEMSELVES
A LINE I THINK WE CAN. WE CAN
REALLY BOOST OUR ECONOMY AND
HOPEFULLY SOLVE THIS CLEAN AIR
CRISIS IN THE CLIMATE CRISIS AT
THE SAME TIME SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB
FIVE FIVE ONE. SENATOR ARCH
ALETTA. OCEAN. OKAY MOTION BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. A MISTER
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE DALLAS FIVE DOLLARS AYE
BATES. HI BATES AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA HI PARTULA HI BAKER.
CORTESE HI PATAGIA DOLLY NOPE
KELLY NO DOT HI DODD HI WHERE.
MELENDEZ YEAH MAN ALL RIGHT MAN
HI NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE RUBIO
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER. NUMBER
HI. NUMBER OF I Y. CASKEY. WILK
BY BOOK I. TEN ONE OKAY THANK
WILL THE BILL ON CALL CENTERS
STERN OKAY NEXT WE HAVE MY BILL
WILL BE S. B. C. TWO ALL TURN
THE GUY OVER TO MADAM VICE
CHAIR SO BATES. I'LL BE RIGHT
OVER. THANK YOU. WELCOME SAID
SENATOR GONZALEZ PLEASE PRESENT
YOUR BILL WHICH IS SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR GOOD MORNING- GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- PRESENTING
SB SEVEN TWO SIX WHICH MAKES
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM MORE EQUITY FOCUSED AND
WILL REQUIRE A COLLABORATIVE
INTERAGENCY PLANNING TO
OFFICIALLY PROMOTE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
CURRENTLY ALLOCATES ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. SB
SEVEN TWO SIX WILL MODERNIZE
ITS PROGRAM AND FOCUSED ON
ADVANCING EQUITY I'VE MADE THE
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY CLEAR AND
RECENT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS WHICH
REQUIRE THE PROGRAM TO SPEND
50% OF ITS FUNDS TO BENEFIT LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THESE BENEFITS
INCLUDE GETTING DIESEL POWERED
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
OFF THE ROAD AS EMISSIONS FROM
THESE TRUCKS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT LOW INCOME. AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SB
SEVEN TWO SIX ALSO ADVANCES
EQUITY BY MAKING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND LOW INCOME
AND IN THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. IN ADDITION TO
PRIORITIZING EQUITY IN THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM SB
SEVEN TWO SIX ALSO PLANS FOR
THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION BY CREATING A
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
STRATEGY. WHICH WILL IDENTIFY
AND DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
GOALS IN THE SECTOR AS A WHOLE.
FINALLY IT'LL REQUIRE THE
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT A LEAD
AGENCY TO OVERSEE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT. FOCUSING ON
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS IN EQUITY AND
DEVELOPING DATA DRIVEN AND
COLLABORATIVE STRATEGIES FOR
THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IS NECESSARY. WE
HAVE TO WORK TOWARDS A
BRIGHTER. GREENER HEALTHIER
FUTURE FOR ALL. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY HAVE MEREDITH
ALEXANDER REPRESENTING CAL
START AND BILL MCGOVERN POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE COALITION OF
CLEAN AIR. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF WOOD THE
WITNESSES ARE LEAD WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT MODERATOR ON ARE
THEY ON THE LINE AND WHICH TO
PROCEED WITH THEIR TESTIMONY.
YES THEIR LIVES ARE OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GONZALEZ
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M MEREDITH ALEXANDER POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CAL START HERE AT
THE SPONSORED SB SEVEN TWO SIX
FIRST WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR HER WONDERFUL
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND FOR
OFFERING THAT MEASURE.
HEALTHCARE TO THE MEMBER BASED
NONPROFIT WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MEMBERS DEDICATED
TO TRANSFORMING THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS COMPRISED OF
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY AND
ALTERNATE PRETTY THIRD PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SUITES AND MORE.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
A CRITICAL ELEMENT OF OUR STATE
TRANSPORTATION CREDIT PROGRAM
HOWEVER THE STATE HAS PASSED
MANY LANDMARK CREDIT LAWS THE
PROGRAM OFFERS THE DALLAS TIME
UP FIFTEEN YEARS AGO AND SINCE
THEN WE'VE ADOPTED AMBITIOUS
MANDATEFOR CLEAN VEHICLES AND
FAT VEHICLE EMISSION REDUCTION
TARGET. SO IT MAKES SENSE TO
MODIFY THE STATUTES THAT GUIDE
THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
REFLECT OUR CURRENT GOAL. AND
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT. THE
WE CAN REALLY AND THE PACE
ACROSS. WE THINK THAT AND I
TAKE INTO THAT. TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS.
MISSION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CLEAN TRANSFERRED. FOR
DISADVANTAGED AND LEARN
COMMUNITIES. AND WILL BE VERY
BY ENSURING THAT OVER HALF OF
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FUND-
WILL BENEFIT THESE COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING BY REPLACING. VEHICLE
AND THE AMENDMENT ALSO HOW TO
ENSURE THAT AGENCIES CAN BEST
WORK TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THEIR
SHARED. GOALS AND TARGETS.
THANK WE REALLY THINK PROGRAM
IS MORE FOR THAN EVER. WE NEED
TO REACH ONE AND A HALF MEN
LIKE THE LECTURE VEHICLE
CHARGERS TWENTY THIRTY AND
RAPIDLY UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUPPORTS MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY COMMERCIAL VEHICLES. AND
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
HAPPY TO SPONSOR THE BILL AND
WORK WITH SENATOR GONZALEZ. AND
IF YOU CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS A
CALL TO MAKE FURTHER. ENHANCING
AND WE RESPECTFULLY AFTER I
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS THE ONLY WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
I ALSO SERVE ON THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION'S ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION WHICH WORKS ON
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. THE COMMISSION. WE ARE
PART OF THE CHARGE HEAD PALETTE
CAN. WHICH. LEGISLATURE
SPONSORED. THAT MADE IT SPOKE
ALL. TO THE TRANCE SECTOR IN A
MINUTE OF AN INCH THAT ALL
CATTLE. THIS THOSE WHO ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THE. IF YOU WERE
POLLUTION CAN THAT THE THAT
TRANCE. CAN PROVIDE. AND SO
THINK THAT MEASURE IS
APPROPRIATE AND WELL TIMES WE
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE
INCREASED FOCUS ON REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION. AND SIGNING UP FOR
STRUCTURE FOR MEDIUM. AND HEAVY
DUTY CLING TRANSFERRED WHAT FOR
HELP TO CLEAN UP THE BIG SOURCE
OF THEIR IN HEALTH WHICH IS
DIESEL. FROM GOODS MOVEMENT. WE
ALSO THANK THE ALL OF THE RE
MAN WERE. THAT LEAST FIFTY OF
THE FARMS. AND IF FOR PROJECT
THAT BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED AND
LOW INCOME CAN. AND FOR ALL
PROMOTE ECO ENTRANCE. WHICH IS
SORELY NEED. WE AGREE WITH THE
CAN IN OUR THAT ASSURE FOCUS
WOULD MAKE THIS BILL EVEN
BETTER. AND WE RECOMMEND SOME
ADDITIONAL.
QUANTIFIABLE
METRICS SO. LOOKING IN THE
GALLERY I DO NOT SEE ANY- DOWN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ALL ARE NONE
THERE THEY'RE NOT MODERATOR
WILL YOU PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM MINE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO DILLON JAFFA
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING A FIFTY. WE HAVE A
REPORT AMENDED POSITION FOR THE
OUT THERE ARE. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS WILL BARRETT AT
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION-
OUT WANTED TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE DIRECTION THE BILL'S
TAKING IN THE QUARTER CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND NOT
STAKEHOLDERS TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD- IN A PRODUCTIVE THANK
YOU. ONE ONE HUNDRED AND THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS BILL MURPHY
WITH ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION NOR
CALISTO CAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT.
MY ONE HUNDRED AND SO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE ON BEHALF OF
THE NOW. SOME CHANGE AS THE
ANAHEIM TRANSFER NETWORK WELL
AS I THE LION ELECTRIC COMPANY
PHOENIX MOTOR CAR ARE VOLVO
GROUP NORTH AMERICA MOTIVE
POWER SYSTEM. HOWEVER COMPANY
MEANT SOMETHING CORPORATION AB
COMPANY MY TRANSIT AGENCY
BALLARD BUT- AND ALLOW VALLEY
AUTHORITY AMPLE POWER AND HE
NEEDS SECTOR COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JULIE ALLEN AFTER FIVE
AND A HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION CALLING IN IN SUPPORT
OF MOVING SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
ALONG THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW
GOAL TO INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION-
FINISHER GONZALEZ IS THERE A
LEAD WITNESS I DON'T SEE THAT
ON THE SCRIPT FOR OPPOSITION.
WE DO NOT HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANKFULLY THEN
I'LL GO TO THE GALLERY TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY ON
NOR ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
THEREFORE LET'S GO TO THE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
SENATE- BILL. SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MADAM AND LATEST
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
OPERATOR HI GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE TRUTH THE CAR CAME
BACK IMPROPER AT THE CALIFORNIA
HAS COALITION A PRO FROM MY
FAMILY. ON THANK THANK I'M. WE
DO BELIEVE THE OFFER BONTA THE
BANNER THAT ARE HEAVY IN MEDIA
DUTY I FEEL A- SURE THANK YOU
CAN DEVELOPER. IMPROPER FOR
THROUGHOUT THE A PART OF ORG.
HI. THE AMOUNT OF A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE ABILITY TO GROW
AND SCALE THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE. GIVEN THE
COMMITTEE EARLIER APPROVAL OF
SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE I'M
ALLOWING THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THE MANUFACTURING
SUPPLY CHAIN THAT THERE MUST BE
A CORE. HIGHLY JACK RIDES FOR
SB SEVEN TWENTY THANK IN THE
BAD WEATHER EIGHT FIVE I'M SURE
A LOT OF THE ENTIRE AND- GROW
FROM LIGHT DUTY AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES I'M SUCH THAT WE CAN
REACH A FINAL. QUESTION THE
REPORT TO THE- WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND AUTHOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- MODERATOR ANY. INTO ON
THE TOP LINE WERE TO. AND OFF.
WE HAVE NO FOR COMMENT IN THE
UP QUEUE FOR SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU THEN WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF MANY
ALL COMMENTS SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM CULTURE I'D
LIKE TO ADD MY FULL SUPPORT TO
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX
AND A HALF TO BE A- A CO CHAIR
AND FOR THE RECORD. I'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU WHY I AM SO.
EXCITED ABOUT TO BUILD THE
THINGS WE'RE DOING HERE IN THE
SENATE TO PROTECT OUR AIR AND-
THINK ABOUT ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT LIVE NEAR SEVENTIES
CORRIDORS AND I FOR THE RECORD
THE SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY TWO.
I HAVE GOT THE SIX OH FIVE
FREEWAY THE NINETY ONE FREEWAY
THE FIVE FREEWAY THE TEN
FREEWAY THE ONE OH FIVE FREEWAY
AND THE SIXTY FREEWAY. SO WHEN
WE HAVE A BILL LIKE THIS IT
TAKES EVERYTHING INTO
CONSIDERATION THE DISADVANTAGED
LOW INCOME WHEN IT TALKS ABOUT
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
STRATEGY IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE SUPPORT A BILL LIKE THIS AND
I'M SO PROUD THAT YOU PUT IT.
BEFORE US AND I URGE THEM AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. THERE ARE
NONE. SENATOR GONZALEZ YOU MAY
CLOSE YES THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW FOR YOUR COMMENTS I WANT
TO THANK OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL WE'VE GOT A GREAT PLANNING
DOCUMENT HERE AND WE INVITE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE A PART OF
THE PROCESS NOT CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS. TO ENSURE-
THAT EVERYBODY'S VOICE IS HEARD
IN THE SPACE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL.
THANK YOU ARE I MEAN MISSED MY
OPPORTUNITY MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT ON IDEA TO OBTAIN ANY
Q. R. SINCE THAT TIME YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING. VERY DILIGENTLY
WITH THE ARM. I WOULDN'T CALL
THEM THE OPPOSITION SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED FOLKS SO I'M GONNA
SUPPORT TODAY AND KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GONNA GO. A FULLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WITHOUT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
THEN MADAM SECRETARY WILL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DALLAS FIVE
DOLLARS HI BATES HI BATES HI
HELEN. ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA
HI BAKER. CORTESE HI CORTESE
AYE GOLLY. DODD HI DOT HI GLARE
I JUST WENT. MAN HI MAN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN I RUBIO HI RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. NUMBER. NUMBER HI
BY COUNTY. WILK HI WELCOME BYE.
WELL THE MEDIA. TEN ZERO. I'M
SORRY OF TEN ZERO AND THEN WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE
WHO WERE. ABSENT AT THE MOMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
VICE CHAIR FREESHEET THAT- NEXT
IN OUR FINAL BILL IS.BY OUR
VICE CHAIRS BATES. IT IS S. B.
SEVEN SIX ZERO. WELCOME AGAIN
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN- WITH THE
VERY SINCERE APPRECIATION TO
CHAIR GONZALEZ AND COMMITTEE
STAFFER THERE IS STILL SYSTEMS
WITH EVERY ASPECT OF THIS-
COMPLEX TRANSPORTATION ISSUE
ARE THE ANALYSIS THEIR
RESPONSES TO BOTH THE
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT QUITE
RESPECTFUL AND QUITE THOROUGH
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE IT
IS A IT HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT
PATH. I BEGIN WITH A QUICK
BACKGROUND LEADING UP TO MY
INTRODUCTION OF SB SEVEN SIXTY
WHICH WOULD DELETE THE
ALIGNMENT OF SR TWO FORTY ONE
TOLL ROAD SOUTH OF WILL ALSO
PARKWAY ON MARCH TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY THE TCA BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS DECIDED NOT TO PURSUE
WITH EXTENDING THE APOSTATE
ROUTE TO FORTY ONE TOLL ROAD
FROM ITS CURRENT TERM ENOUGH IT
ALSO PARKWAY WHICH IS AN EAST
WEST ARTERIAL EXTENDING THROUGH
AND BEYOND THE EASTERN BOUNDARY
OF THE CITY OF MISSION VIEJO.
INSTEAD THE BOARD'S ACTION IN
RESPONSE TO TECHNICAL STUDIES
AND PUBLIC OPPOSITION APPROVED
MOVING FORWARD WITH AN UNTOLD
EXTENSION OF LOS PETRONE. IS
PARKWAY ARTERIAL. THE TCP
RELEASE HERALDED THIS DECISION
AND I CALLED TO SEE CHAIRWOMAN
AND MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
IRVINE. AFTER A ROBUST FOR
YEARS OF PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
EFFORT WE'RE HAPPY WE HAVE A
SOLUTION THAT REPRESENTS BOTH
COMMUNITY INPUT AND TECHNICAL
ANALYSIS. THE LAST PETRONIO'S
PARKWAY EXTENSION WILL RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT REGIONAL
MOBILITY IMPROVEMENT. IN OUR
APPROVAL MEANS THAT ALL OTHER
ALTERNATIVES INCLUDING ALL
ROUTES. THAT CONNECT DIRECTLY
TO INTERSTATE FIVE ARE REMOVED
FROM CONSIDERATION AND THIS
CONCLUDES TCA'S EFFORTS TO
EXTEND THE TWO FORTY ONE TOLL
ROAD. THIS STATEMENT SHOULD
HAVE SET THE TONE FOR A NEW
ROBUSTUM COLLABORATIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING PROCESS
FOR ALL GOING FORWARD. HOWEVER
THE SUBSEQUENT PUBLIC
STATEMENTS BY SOME BOARD
MEMBERS BEGAN TO ERODE PUBLIC
TRUST. OF BY INDICATING THERE
COULD BE A RENEWED EFFORT TO
REVIVE THE STUDIED ALTERNATIVES
THAT WOULD EXTEND THE TWO FORTY
ONE TO INTERSTATE FIVE THROUGH
SAN CLEMENTE IS PROTECTED OPEN
SPACE. RATHER THAN CONNECTING
THE TWO FORTY ONE TO I. FIVE
SOUTH. OF THE CITY OF SAN
CLEMENTE AS CURRENTLY SET FORTH
IN THE CALIFORNIA STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS CODE SECTION FIVE FOUR
ONE. CENT COMMITTEE SOUGHT
ASSURANCES OVER TIME THAT THE
TCA'S MARCH TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY DECISION WAS IN FACT THE
FINAL WORD ON THE ISSUE.
HOWEVER THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED
AND AT THE CITY'S REQUEST I WAS
PROMPTED TO INTRODUCE SB SEVEN
SIXTY LEGISLATION WHICH AS I
SAID SEEKS TO MEMORIALIZE TCA'S
MARCH TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY
DECISION. BY DELETING THE
ALIGNMENT FSR TWO FORTY ONE
SOUTH OF ALSO PARKWAY IT IS
DUPLICATIVE OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE WHICH I
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR. WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE BUT
NEVER A CHEN DICE IN ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION. DUE TO THE CALL
VIA THE BILL LIMITATION. MY
GOAL WITH THIS LEGISLATION
MEMORIALIZING TO SEIZE MARCH
DECISION IS TWO FOLD ONE
REESTABLISH THE TRUST THAT WAS
INHERENT WHEN THAT DECISION WAS
MADE AND SECONDLY. ENCOURAGE
ALL INVOLVED THE TCA THE- CTA
ABOUT THE TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AGENCIES THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AND THE
REGION'S CITIESTO BEGIN AGAIN.
THE COLLABORATIVE AND ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON TRAFFIC
CONGESTION RELIEF SOLUTIONS I
AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT AS A
RESULT. OF THIS BILL TCA
CHAIRMAN PEGGY WONG AND
DISTRICT FIVE SOUTH COUNTY
SUPERVISOR LISA BARTLETT HAD
TAKEN THE LEAD AND CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAVE JUST BEGUN. AND PRESENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO FIND CONSENSUS
SOLUTIONS AND ELIMINATE THE
YEARS LONG CONTROVERSY THAT HAS
PERSISTED AND CONTRIBUTED TO
PREVENTING SOME PLANNED
PROJECTS MOVING FORWARD. HERE
JUST BECAUSE LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIXTY ARE
KATHY WARD MAYOR SAM FOR MANY.
IN THE ON MARKET PRAYER. ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
CLEMENTE. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES- WILL START WITH
MARK HUGHES HERE IN THE GALLERY
GO RIGHT AHEAD MARK THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU MY NAME IS MARK OF PRIOR
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN CLEMENTE. THE EXTENSION
OF THE TWO FORTY RUN- TOLL ROAD
WAS DROPPED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF THE TCA BOARD ON MARCH
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY. SB SEVEN
SIXTY AFFIRMS OF THAT DECISION.
THE IRONY OF THE TCA'S
OPPOSITION TO SEVEN SIXTY NOW.
IS THAT THE DENTURE THE
FOOTHILL EASTERN BORDER THE TCA
CRISTINA CHEZ ANTI CA CEO
SAMUEL JOHNSON. URGED CENTER
BASE O AMEND LAST YEAR'S
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE. WITH A LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY IN SEVEN SIXTY ONLY
TO HAVE THE TCA BOARD WEEKS
LATER VOTE TO OPPOSE THE
MEASURE. UNFORTUNATELY THE TCA
HAS A WELL EARNED REPUTATION
FOR PROPOSING TOLL ROADS
THROUGH ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREAS. AND NOT
KEEPING THEIR COMMITMENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE TCA FIRST PROPOSED
A TOLL ROAD THROUGH THE SAN
ONOFRE STATE PARK. THAT
PROPOSED TOLL ROAD ENDED IN A
LEGAL SETTLEMENT. WHEREBY THE
TCA WILL PAY TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
RESTORATION OF A WATERSHED NEAR
CAMP PENDLETON. BUT ONLY IF THE
TCA COMPLETES AN ALTERNATIVE
ROUTE FOR THE TWO FORTY ONE
EXTENSION. THIS AGREEMENT HAS
LED TO A PERVERSE OUTCOME WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
MONEY MAY ONLY GET PAID IF THE
TCA IS ABLE TO DESTROY OPEN
SPACE. AND CONSERVATION.
EASEMENTS IN SAN CLEMENTE. THIS
YEAR ON A NINETEENTH TCA
PROPOSED A NEW PLANNING POLICY.
WHICH RE OPENED THE PROSPECT OF
EXTENDING THE TWO FORTY ONE.
JUST A YEAR AFTER DROPPED THAT
OPTION. T. C. A. CLAIM THAT IT
WAS A PRODUCT OF A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS. BUT CTA
IN ORANGECOUNTY RESPONDED THE
TCA MADE NO REQUEST FOR INPUT
FROM THEM. SAN CLEMENTE AGREES
WITH- CTA CEO DURRELL'S JOHNSON
IN HIS LETTER TO THE TCA. WORRY
SAID THE PROPOSED POLICY WORKS
CONTRARY TO ATTEMPT TO RESOLVE
THE CONCERNS THAT LED TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF SB SEVEN SIXTY.
AS THE TCA TESTIFIED LAST YEAR
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. THE
TCA'S MARCH TWELVE DECISION TO
ABANDON THE TWO FORTY ONE TOLL
ROAD AND SUPPORT THE EXTENSION
OF THE LOST PATROL IS PARKWAY.
WILL ENSURE NEEDED TRAFFIC
RELIEF UNTIL TWENTY FIFTY. IN
CONCLUSION IF DOWN THE ROAD
THERE IS A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THE CITY
OF SAN CLEMENTE. AS IT DID IN
SUPPORTING THE LOST PETRONIUS
PARKWAY EXTENSION WHICH WILL
RUN THROUGH SAN CLEMENTE WILL
STEP UP TO DO ITS FAIR SHARE.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB SEVEN SIXTY TO
KEEP THE DEAL AT ALL PARTIES
AGREE TO LAST YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR FRYE F. ATIONS
THERE AS WELL- SENATOR BATES
DID YOU HAVE ONE OTHER WITNESS
IN SUPPORT I ONLY HAVE
DOCUMENTED ONE THE STAFF FIVE
COUNTY WARD MAYOR SAN CLEMENTE
OKAY. MAY WE HAVE THE MAYOR-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE ENSURE
THE MAYOR IS ON THE LINE FOR.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN SIXTY. YES WE DO HAVE
MAYOR WARD ON THE LINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KATHY WARD MAYOR OF SAN
CLEMENTE ON BEHALF OF THE
RESIDENTS OF SAN CLEMENTE I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR BATES FOR
HER CONTINUING EFFORTS TO FIND
A SOLUTION. TO THE
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES
FACING ORANGE COUNTY AND
EXPRESS OUR FULL SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN SIXTY. ON MARCH TWELFTH
TWENTY TWENTY THE TCA BOARD
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO CONCLUDE
THE AGENCY'S EFFORTS. TO
IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS FOR
SOUTHERNLY EXTENSION AT THE
STATE ROUTE TO FORTY ONE TOTAL
ROAD AND INSTEAD DECIDED TO
SUPPORT EXTENDING THE LOCAL
CHARMS PARKWAY AND TWO OTHER
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
SUBSEQUENTLY CALTRANS THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. AND THE TCA
COLLECTIVELY AGREED. LAST YEAR
SENATOR BATES INTRODUCED SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE TO
CODIFY THAT DECISION AND THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
AND THE FULL SENATE VOTED TO
APPROVE THAT BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO CONVERT
NINETEEN SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WAS NOT SET FOR HEARING
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
SENATOR BATES INTRODUCED AN
IDENTICAL BILL IN SB SEVEN
SIXTY. JUST LAST WEEK THE TCA
PROPOSED THE POLICY TO
CONTEMPLATE A FUTURE SOUTHERN
EXTENSION OF THEIR TOLL ROAD.
THAT CLEARLY INDICATES THAT TCS
CONSIDERING BACKING AWAY FROM
THEIR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO
VOTE AND THE SUBSEQUENT
AGREEMENT BY CALTRANS AND OF
THE TA. TCA IS NOT A TRUSTED
PARTNER- CPAC E. O. DALE
JOHNSON STATED LAST WEEK IN A
LETTER TO THE TCA THAT THE
PROPOSED POLICY WORKS AGAINST
RESOLVING THE CONCERNS THAT LED
TO THE INTRODUCTION OF SB SEVEN
SIXTY. AS STATED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ORANGE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR LISA BARTLETT
HAS CONVENED A WORKING GROUP TO
DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN ALL PARTIES.
SB SEVEN SIXTY PROVIDED A
CATALYST FOR THOSE EFFORTS AND
WE ASK LIKE YOU DID LST YEAR
THAT YOU PROVIDE CENTER BATES
THE TOOLS NEEDED TO BRING THESE
DISCUSSIONS TO A SUCCESSFUL
CONCLUSION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON SB SEVEN
SIXTY THANK YOU MAYOR WARD WE
APPRECIATE THAT SO AGAIN
EVERYONE HAS BEEN GIVEN TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW- INSURE THAT
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT
NEEDS TO TESTIFY WE ARE GIVEN.
EACH SIDE FIFTEEN MINUTES- I'M
LOOKING TO THE GALLERY TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
NO ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS IN THE
GALLERY ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THERE SO
WILL MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO YOU FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIXTY
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND ENSURE THAT
YOUR IN SUPPORT EVERYBODY IS
COLLECTIVELY GOING TO BE GIVEN
FIFTEEN MINUTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT PRESS
TOGETHER THE LINE NUMBERS.
ONE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND USE THE KEY.
WHAT MIGHT PUSH THANKS. HI I'M
DIANA GOT FOUNDER OF NONTOXIC
SAN DIEGO. AND LOS ANGELES A
MEMBER OF THE NO TOLL ROAD IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN SIXTY. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIRMAN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER. SACRAMENTO
COUNTY COMMISSIONER OF COURSE.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME IS PATRICIA HOLLOWAY I AM
A RESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY THE
RETIRED TRUSTEE WITH THE
CAPISTRANO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SERVING THE MAJORITY
OF SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY. I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIXTY.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS BILL FOR IN RICHEST IN
ORANGE COUNTY I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB SEVEN SIXTY. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY MOM SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY BE A MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHERRY CALL OVER. LONG TIME
RESIDENT OF SAN CLEMENTE.
TOTALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
BATES BILL S. B. SEVEN SIXTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME'S TONI ISEMAN I'M ON
THE LAGUNA BEACH CITY COUNCIL
SERVED. MORE THAN FOUR TERMS-
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT. EIGHT
SEVEN SIXTY IT AND HERE- ALL.
AN IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE LOOKED AT- WE
HAVE USED THANK YOU MA'AM WE'RE
JUST TAKING NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL ARE NOT MY
APOLOGIES. AND MADAM CHAIR AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SIXTY OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION-
AT THIS TIME. AND LET'S SEE WHO
WE HAVE AS LATE OPPOSITION HERE
WE HAVE NEEDS ALL OF.
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AGENCY
THE TCA AS WELL AS DAN SILVER
AND INJURED HABITATS LEAGUE A
MODERATOR CAN YOU ENSURE THAT A
MISTRESS ALL OF HIS ON THE LINE.
THE FINAL SIDE THEY GO AHEAD-
INEXORABLE ME AFTER THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCIES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
WERE OPPOSED TO SB SEVEN SIXTY
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ONE CITY IN
ORANGE COUNTY TRYING TO
PERMANENTLY BLOCK FUTURE ROAD
CONSTRUCTION NEARLY EVERY OTHER
CITY IN THE REGION AS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING REQUIRES REGIONAL
COOPERATION. AS OPPOSED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS BECAUSE IT
IMPACTS THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE AND THREATENS PLANNED FOR
OPEN SPACE FUNDING AS OPPOSED
BY LABOR BECAUSE OF BLOCKS
FEATURE JOBS AND IT'S OPPOSED
BY LOCAL BUSINESS AND
TRANSPORTATION GROUPS BECAUSE
WILL PREVENT TRAFFIC SOLUTIONS.
THE QUESTION BEFORE YOU WITH
THIS WILL YOU PICK ONE CITY
ABOVE ALL THE OTHER CITIES IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY AND ALLOW
SAN CLEMENTE'S TOOK FOREVER
BALK ROAD CONSTRUCTION AT THE
EXPENSE OF EVERYONE ELSE WELL
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THE
DISPUTE TURNED INTO A TWO YEAR
BATTLE SO ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
FROM THE REGION CAN CONTINUE
WORKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
CREATE A LOCAL SOLUTION. IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE FOR THE STATE
TO STEP INTO A LOCAL.
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING ISSUE.
THAT'S NOT GOOD POLICY ALLOW IN.
CITIES TO CAL. AND OTHER.
AGENTS FROM THE- FUTURE OPTION.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THOUSANDS OF
NEW HOMES WILL BE BUILT ALONG
THIS CORRIDOR THE COMING YEARS.
THERE'S ALSO PENDING LITIGATION
FROM THE CITY OF SAN CLEMENTE
TRYING TO BLOCK FUTURE ROADS IN
THE COLLECTION OF REVENUE TO
PAY FOR WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
BUILT. THIS BILL COULD IMPACT
EXISTING AND FUTURE LITIGATION.
THE BILL SHOULD BE WITHDRAWN SO
THAT THE LOCAL CITIES AND
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES CAN
WORK OUT A SOLUTION. WELL
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE FOR WEEKS TO TRY
AN INTERESTING COMMENTARIES
CONCERN AND EVERYONE IN THE
REGION IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THOSE MEETINGS SO
EVERYTHING CAN BE REACHED. ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE OPPOSITION
GROUPS INCLUDING LABOR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS BUSINESS
GROUPS CITIES WITHIN ORANGE
COUNTY AND TRANSPORTATION
GROUPS WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR SOLA. NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
DAN SILVER FROM THE ENDANGERED
HABITATS LEAGUE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION. AND OUR
DC ON THE PHONE MODERATOR CAN
YOU ENSURE THAT MISTER. SILVER
IS ON THE LINE. MISTER SOBERS
MINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD DAY CHOI GONZALEZ AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND YOU HEARD
I'M SILVERBIRD ANYTHING SHOULD
HAPPEN CAPS IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AS MEMBERS OF THE
STATE SENATE OPERATE COALITION
WE OPPOSE SB SEVEN SIXTY. WE DO
NOT SEE A LEGITIMATE PURPOSE
FOR THE BILL AT THIS TIME AFTER
FIFTEEN YEARS OF FIGHTING TO
SAVE SEVEN NO. EACH ONE SIGNED
A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WITH THE
TEACHING DAY DESIGNATING AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ACCEPTABLE AREA
FOR TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
CALTRANS AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY SIGNED THE
RELATED PROTECTIVE AGREEMENT.
IF YOU SEE A THAT IMPLEMENTED A
LOCAL PLANNING PROCESS BASED ON
THE REGION'S FUTURE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND ASSESS
THE COR RANGE OF ALTERNATIVES
THE RESULT WAS A RECOMMENDATION
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE TO
BUILD THE MOST FRONTRUNNERS
PARKWAY EXTENSION. THIS PROJECT
IS NOT MOVING FORWARD. THIS
CHOICE WAS PER BY THE SIGNATURE
CLEMENTE. IT TRAFFIC IN BAR
EXCEPT MAN KONCZ WITH THE
AGREEMENTS. AND ACTING AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX LAST YEAR
LEGISLATURE CODIFIED PORTIONS
OF THESE AGREEMENTS PROTECTING
THE STATE BEACH AND OTHER
WILDLIFE AREAS. P. C. A. HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT ITS LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS WORKS AND
ACCEPTABLE SOLUTIONS CAN BE
FOUND CAN YOU BELIEVE IT IS
MORE APPROPRIATE TO ENABLE
THESE LOCAL PLANNING EFFORTS
INCLUDING AN ONGOING
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. TO ADOPT
PREMATURE LEGISLATION THAT
COULD INTERFERE WITH THE TICE'S
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ITS
TRANSPORTATION PLANS AND
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT ITSELF. WE
ARE AS WE DO NOT FIND A REASON
WHY THE BILL WAS NEED. YOUR
NAME COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OTHERS THROUGH THE ONGOING
LOCAL PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER SILVER OKAY WE'VE
CONCLUDED. LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WILL MOVE TO
GALLERY. WE'LL SEE WE SEE NOW
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SIXTY.
ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NINE. NOW
MODERATOR WILL GO BACK TO YOU
FOR WITNESSES ARE PEOPLE ONCE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SIXTY
AND AGAIN WE'RE ALLOTTING
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN SIXTY MY NAME MICHELLE
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE LAGUNA CANYON CONSERVANCY
CREATE SUPPORT SB SEVEN SIXTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ONCE AGAIN- ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN. OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SIXTY PLEASE MOVE AHEAD
PLEASE PROCEED. ONE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE CAROLINE I AM ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORTER AND HE'S
SEVEN SIXTY AND I WAS NOT ABLE
TO EARLIER AND I'M WITH THE
CATHOLIC HERE'S A NONPROFIT
ADVOCACY GROUP THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIRED
MEMBERS ARE WE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SIXTY.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS TIFFANY
ACKLEY I'M THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF THE LEAST THE VA HEALTH
POLICE TO BE HAS TO THE FEW
MILES NORTH OF SPENT THE MONEY.
AND WILL BE A BIG SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED BY THE BILL. MY
BIPARTISAN COUNCIL MY
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO NOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I HUMBLY
ASK FOR YOU TO VOTE MAY. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. LINE
ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR ONLY BE ALL I AM
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
SANTA MARGARITA I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE FOOTHILL EASTERN
TCA BOARD OF DIRECTORS CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SIXTY THIS BILL DOES NOT
CODIFY ARE MEMORIALIZED. THE
ROAD WE'RE JUST TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
OPPOSE THE BILL ARE NOT I
APOLOGIZE NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AM
TRISH KELLY I AM THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF MISSION VIEJO AND I
EXPRESSED STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN SIXTY. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS RICHARD
HURT I AM A- WILL BE ABLE. AYE
OPPOSED SB SEVEN SIXTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. NINE ONE SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SEVEN EIGHT NINE NINE
AND OPEN. YES EGGMAN FONG I'M
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY AND YOUR
BILL AND THAT'S- AND I AM
VOICING MY OPPOSITION TO THE
SEVEN SIXTY WITH EVERYTHING
OUTLINED IN OUR MATTER. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE FORTY SEVEN. LEVINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO HOME. AND WE CAN HELP
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE MY
APOLOGIES OPPOSED TO THE SENATE
BILL ONE SEVENTY THERE. THANK
YOU ONE ONE FORTY TWO. IF WE
MAY HAVE YOU REPEAT. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER POINTERS. WHAT THE SAN
JUAN CAPISTRANO AND WE'RE GOING
TO HELP CAME. AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL AND
SEVEN MIL. ONE ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
IMPAIR THIS IS JAMES THEIR LACK
YOUR WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL OF LABOR'S STRONG
OPPOSITION. YEAH. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND JUST AS A REMINDER
IF YOU CAN TURN DOWN THE GYM.
NINE ONE SIXTY THREE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRENT.
RENDON RUBIO I'M CALLING FROM
THE ECONOMIC. SOUTHWEST HOW
QUICK GET IT BACK THE OLD- THE-
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
LINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE THREE MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF MISSION
BEING OUT. THIS IS A CONTACT
AND ON. YEAH BUT HE'S COMING
BACK AFTER TALKING. FOR IF YOU
THINK NEXT NEXT COMMENT PLEASE
I THINK THAT IN. OKAY. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY. THREE
SEVEN THREE NINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD I THINK THAT RESEARCH.
GET A MANAGER MEETING MEMBERS
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE MOLINA I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BEAUTIFUL THING COMMITTEE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN SIXTY.
THANK YOU WATER YOUR PLANTS.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN SIXTY. WE HAVE ONE
LAST MINE MINE ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LONG. AMERICANS MANY OF
THOSE. THANK YOU. ANYMORE IN
THE QUEUE. FOR OPPOSITION ONE
LAST TIME. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE OPPOSITION TO
THANK YOU MODERATOR GREAT WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WE'LL TAKE THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MEMBERS. I SEE SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR SPEAKING ON THIS
SINCE I KNOW WERE ALL LATE FOR
LUNCH- BUT THIS DOES AFFECT MY
DISTRICT- I'VE BEEN LATE COMING
TO A POSITION ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BECAUSE I
WANTED TO DO MY RESEARCH AND-
HEAR OUT ALL THE DIFFERENT
PLAYERS AND I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SOME GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
RESPECTFULLY I DO NEED TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION I'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNS OF SAN CLEMENTE
RESIDENTS AND I APPRECIATE
THOSE. THE FATE OF THE TWO
FORTY ONE IS NOT SOLELY ABOUT
ONE CITY OR EVEN ONE
SENATE-DISTRICT. IT'S A
REGIONAL ISSUE THAT IMPACTS ALL
OF ORANGE COUNTY. BUT
ESPECIALLY CITIES LIKE LAGUNA
HILLS. LISA VIEJO RANCHO SANTA
MARGARITA MISSION VIEJO IRVINE
TUSTIN. ANAHEIM HILLS IN VILLA
PARK AND YOU'VE HEARD FROM MANY
OF THE LEADERS OF THOSE REGIONS
AND CITIES. IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. MY DISTRICT HAS AN
ESPECIALLY STRONG STAKE IN WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE TWO FORTY ONE
CENSUS WILL HAVE POTENTIALLY A
HUGE IMPACT ON OUR CONGESTION
AND TRAFFIC GOING FORWARD. NOW
THIS IS WHY THE DISCUSSIONS
OVER THE TWO FORTY ONE HAVE
INVOLVED NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING NOT ONLY TCA BUT ALSO
THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
CALTRANS. WITH SIGNIFICANT
INPUTS FROM LOCAL CITIES AND
THE REPRESENTATIVES INCLUDING
SAN CLEMENTE. THIS MULTI YEAR
MULTI STAKEHOLDER APPROACH LED
AN AGREEMENT MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TO END AND FOR ITS TO
EXPAND TO EXPAND THE TWO FORTY
ONE INSTEAD FOCUS ON THREE
PROJECTS TO ALLEVIATE TRAFFIC.
IN THE NEAR TERM. LAST WEEK'S
PCA UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED A
RESOLUTION ENDING ALL EFFORTS
TO EXTEND THE TWO FORTY ONE
UNLESS CERTAIN BURKE BENCHMARKS
WERE MET. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE ONLY REASON THIS
RESOLUTION HAS NOT BEEN MORE
FORMALIZED IS BECAUSE SAN
CLEMENTE WANTED MORE
PROTECTIONS. AND THESE ARE
BEING ADOPTED INTO THE
RESOLUTION. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT HERE THAT WE
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN SHORT
TERM VERSUS LONG TERM
PRIORITIES. LOOKING AT THE MAP
OF TWO FORTY ONE IF YOU WANNA
PULL THAT UP ON YOUR PHONE YOU
CAN SEE IT ENDS ABRUPTLY RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE COULD CAUSE IN
MISSION VIEJO. THE IDEA WAS
ALWAYS TO HAVE THE TWO FORTY
ONE CONNECTED TO FIVE AND
THAT'S WHY THE CALIFORNIA CODE
IS WRITTEN THE WAY IT IS. IN
THE SHORT RUN I BECOME
CONVINCED BY CENTER BATES AND
REPRESENTATIVES MET SAN
CLEMENTE. THAT A TWO FORTY ONE
EXTENSION OF THE FIVE IS NOT
NECESSARY- AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT ALL PARTIES
AGREE UPON. BUT THAT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE THE CASE IN THE
LONG RUN WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
OVER THE LONG RUN HAVING THE
TWO FORTY ONE TO THE FIVE MAY
BE. SEEN AS DESIRABLE OR
NECESSARY FOR REDUCING
CONGESTION. IMPROVING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND FACILITATING
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY IN THE
REGION INCLUDING MANY KEY
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT. IT MAY
WELL BE THE CASE THAN FIVE
YEARS AND TEN YEARS IN FIFTEEN
YEARS WE DECIDED WE VERY WELL
NEED THIS EXPANSION. NOW IT'S
BEEN SAID THAT THIS BILL
CODIFIES THE AGREEMENT BUT IT
ACTUALLY GOES MUCH FURTHER THAN
THAT IF PERMANENTLY ENDS THE
POSSIBILITY TO TWO FORTY ONE
EXTENSION. TAKING AWAY AN
OPTION THAT I THINK ALL OF OUR
REGIONAL TRANSIT AUTHORITIES IN
CITIES. RECOGNIZE COULD BE AN
IMPORTANT ROUTE IN THE FUTURE
FOR EASING CONGESTION. WE IN
THE LEGISLATURE WIELD AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF POWER AND I
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT HOW WE USE THAT POWER.
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT'S TO WEIGH
IN ON A LOCAL ISSUE. THERE ARE
SEVERAL PRINCIPLES AT WORK THAT
CAUSED ME TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIRST WE EITHER WE HAVE THE
PRINCIPLE OF LOCAL CONTROL.
THERE IS A LOCAL PROCESS IN
PLACE HAS BEEN DESCRIBED BY THE
WITNESSES. AND ACHIEVE THE
DESIRED RESULTS THERE ARE NO
PLANS RIGHT NOW. EXTENDED 2401%
COMMITTEE OR ANYONE ANYWHERE
ELSE. SECOND THIS BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM IS TRYING TO SOLVE AND
POTENTIALLY CREATES LONG RUN
PROBLEMS. IF THE GOAL IS TO
PREVENT A SHORT TERM EXPANSION
OF THE AT TWO FORTY ONE THE
BILL IS UNNECESSARY. BUT BY
ENDING A TWO FORTY ONE IT
DESTROYS THE FLEXIBILITY OF
REGIONAL ACTORS TO ADDRESS
TRANSIT ISSUES GOING FORWARD.
THIRD THIS BILL IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR AS IT
FAVORS THE INTERESTS OF ONE
DISTRICT. INDEED ONE CITY. OVER
THE INTERESTS OF OTHER LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS. THE TWO FORTY ONE
ISSUES I MENTION IS NOT JUST
THE SAN CLEMENTE ISSUE IT'S A
REGIONAL ISSUE. THIS BILL
PRIORITIZES THE INTERESTS OF
ONE CITIES ONE CITY OVER THE
INTERESTS OF MANY OTHERS. I
THINK THE LIST OF SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION MAKES THIS VERY
CLEAR THE SUPPORTERS ARE ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY BASED OUT OF SAN
CLEMENTE. WHERE IS THE
OPPOSITION COMES FROM ACROSS
ORANGE COUNTY INCLUDES
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. LABOR
UNIONS CAN BUSINESS COUNCIL.
LEADERS FROM A WIDE ARRAY OF
CITIES INCLUDING IRVINE ANAHEIM
TUSTIN ORANGE YORBA LINDA
MISSION VIEJO RANCHO SANTA
MARGARITA. AND OTHER PLACES. BY
LISA VIEJO AS AS MENTIONED BY
THE MAYOR TIFFANY ACKLEY JUST
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO OPPOSE SB
SEVEN SIXTEEN THEY SENT A
LETTER TO THIS BODY. AND I'D
LIKE PERMISSION FROM MADDEN
CHAIR TO READ A SHORT EXCERPT
FROM THAT. ABSOLUTELY GO RIGHT
AHEAD SENATOR MEANT. THE LETTER
STATES IN PART. THE PROCESS TO
DEFINE MOBILITY SOLUTIONS WITH
THE SUCCESS WHICH IS WHY
LEGISLATION IS UNNECESSARY. AND
MAY UNDERMINE THE GOODWILL AND
TRUST THAT WAS ESTABLISHED AS A
RESULT OF THESE EFFORTS. THIS
MULTI AGENCY THAT SOLUTION
DEMONSTRATES THAT LOCAL ISSUES
CAN BEST BE RESOLVED BY THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. AND
IGNORING THIS REGIONAL APPROACH
COULD SET A BAD PRECEDENT THAT
WOULD ALLOW SMALL SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS TO HALT
REGIONALLY BENEFICIAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE CITY OF SAN
CLEMENTE HAS ATTEMPTED TO
EXCLUDE THEMSELVES FROM
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING PROCESS
OVER THE YEARS. IT'S AN AFFRONT
TO OUR NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
THIS REGARDING OUR MUTUAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR REGIONAL
TRAFFIC. THEIR LACK OF
WILLINGNESS TO PARTICIPATE
EXHIBITS A COMPLETE DISREGARD
FOR THE OTHER CITIES IN THE
REGION. THE CITY OF WE THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE
OUR TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
RESPONSIBILITIES SERIOUSLY. WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORANCE OF
BEING PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
THE REGION'S TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS. AND BELIEVE IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON ALL CITIES TO DO
THEIR PART. NOW I WILL JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT ORANGE
COUNTY IS FACING THIS SAME
DEBATE. ACROSS A WIDE ARRAY OF
ISSUES WHEN THERE COMES TO
HOUSING. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HOUSING THE HOMELESS.
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE LIGHT-
AND THIS IS AGAIN JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF ONE CITY TRYING TO
GET ITS WAY OVER. THE INTERESTS
AND WELL BEING OF THE REST OF
ORANGE COUNTY. SO I'M GONNA
POST THIS AND I RESPECTFULLY-
YOU KNOW ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
THIS SHOULD COME OF OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THIS. IF IT COMES TO
THE FLOOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN SENATOR NEWMAN. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO- I DO
APPRECIATE. ALL THOSE OF THE
SENTIMENTS EXPRESSED BY
SENTIMENT. I DON'T TYPICALLY DO
THIS BUT I I'M GOING TO LIVE
REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
DAY- AND RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
REVISIT THIS ISSUE AS MOVES
FORWARD. THE BASE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- THE
PARTIES HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD
TO FIND. AB ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES- AND- YOU GIVE ME
THAT REASSURANCE AND
APPRECIATED MY UNDERSTANDING IS
ALSO- THAT TOWARD THAT END THE
PARTY SALUTE BLOOD THE
LITIGATION PUTTING SINGLE MAN
YOU'RE PLANNING A MEETING NEXT
WEEK IS THAT STILL CORRECT. AND
SO YOU KNOW WITH THAT IN MIND-
I'M A SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BUT I WOULD URGE ALL THE
PARTIES TO CONTINUE WORKING. ON
THIS ISSUE TO FIND AN AMICABLE
SOLUTION THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I BELIEVE I WANT TO
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS
OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY THAT JUST EXPRESSED ALL
HIS CONCERNS AND QUITE FRANKLY
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'M
HEARING ABOUT THESE CONCERNS-
AND I JUST WANTED TO GO BACK TO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS HAVE HEARD
ON. I THINK IT WAS THE
OPPOSITION THEY WERE STATING
THAT THEY WANTED US TO PULL THE
BILL TO GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER
AND COME TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS
BUT- BUT- CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG I THOUGHT. WE HEARD THIS
BILL LAST YEAR AND I REMEMBER
THOSE COMMENTS WERE THE SAME.
YOU KNOW THEY WANTED THE BILL
TO BE PULLED SO WE CAN WORK ON
IT AND IT'S STILL YOUR LATER
SELF. I'M STILL A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED OTHERS NEW INFORMATION
THAT JUST. BROUGHT FORWARD BY
OUR COLLEAGUE AND SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION SO I'M RESPECTFUL OF
THAT AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S
THIRD DISTRICT BUT FOR ME
BECAUSE I. HAD ALREADY GIVEN MY
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL ALLOW
THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. I'M GONNA
HAVE TO KEEP MY COMMITMENT AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL- BUT I WOULD
APPRECIATE. AGAIN EVERYONE
STILL WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
COMING TOGETHER. IT'S BEEN A
YEAR AND I WOULD HAVE HOPE THAT
THERE WAS PROGRESS ON THE
CONVERSATIONS. ARE AT LEAST
TRYING TO FIND THAT MIDDLE
GROUND BUT- ARE LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY I
WILL RESERVE. THE RIGHT TO
REVISIT THIS ISSUE AND TO ASK
THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AS SHE HAS. VERY DILIGENT NEED
TO COME TO A SOLUTION FOR THEIR
DISTRICTS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR
ALAN. THANK YOU I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- IT IS CLEARLY A
THORNY ISSUE OBVIOUSLY A LOCAL
ISSUE BUT A LOCAL ISSUE THAT
AND- HAS PEOPLE ON ON ON ON
EITHER SIDE AND MUCH OF IT
DEPENDS ON WHICH PART OF ORANGE
COUNTY. QUINCY ONES
REPRESENTING- NO I I'VE LAID
OFF PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THIS
BILL IN THE PAST AND YOU KNOW I.
HI I UNDERSTAND THIS IS THIS IS
A GOING TO BE NEGOTIATED- I
GUESS WHAT I'D LOVE TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF THE- CARE IN
THE COMMITTEE'S. POSITION ON
THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD AND IF
IT DOES MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY I DO UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR
AS AN AYE RECOMMENDATION AYE I
WILL SAY. I CENTER MAN IS A IS
A FORMIDABLE. ADVOCATE FOR HIS-
HIS HIS SIDE OF THE LINE AND
FIX THE ANYONE WHO HEARD HIS
COMMENTS JUST NOW I THINK CAN'T
DENY THAT- YEAH MY TENDENCY IS
TO WANT TO YOU KNOW SUPPORT THE
CHAIR IN IN AN ATTEMPT TO TRY
TO COME TO SOME SORT OF. COMMON
GROUND- SO AS TO YOUR CHART A
PATH MOVING FORWARD IT'S FAIR
TO THE COMMUNITIES INVOLVED IN.
AND YOU KNOW I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT SOME OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
OPPOSITION IT COMES MORE FROM
THE FACT THIS DISRUPTS THE
SETTLEMENT. RATHER THAN ANY
SORT OF- MERIT AS RELATED
RELATING TO THE READING OF THE-
OF THE OF TO THE T. FORTY ONE
AND SO THE I GUESS WHAT I'D
LOVE I'D LOVE TO JUST GET A
BETTER SENSE OF. OF MANAGER
YOUR PLANS MOVING FORWARD OF
THE GUARDS OF THIS BILL AND-
JUST TO GIVE ME A SENSE AS I'M
AS I'M TRYING TO WIN MY VOTE
HERE MY TENDENCY IS ALWAYS TO.
WANT TO SUPPORT YOU IN YOUR-
EFFORTS TO TRY TO. MEDIATE SOME
OF THESE MEETINGS ISSUES HERE
BEFORE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN I DON'T THINK I
SEE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF SENATOR BATES I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I KNOW YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED EXTENSIVELY ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE I'VE TALKED TO
MANY MEMBERS OF COURSE AN
ORANGE COUNTY AS WELL TO GET
THERE'S PERSPECTIVE. I'M
COMMITTED I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND YOU'VE BEEN
IN THIS FOR SOME TIME- SO I
TRUST THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH
EVERYONE AT THE TABLE. WHEN WE
SPOKE THE LAST FRIDAY YOU WERE
YOU HAD TO MEETINGS AT SET THAT
FRIDAY AND I KNOW THAT YOU'LL
CONTINUE THIS ON. MY HOPE EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A VERY SUPER
LOCAL. ISSUE IS THAT AGAIN THAT
THE CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE
IN THAT HOPEFULLY SOME TRUST
COULD BE BUILT OVER THE NEXT. A
FEW MONTHS OR SO. SO WITH THAT
THAT'S WHY I AM SUPPORTING
TODAY- AND I KNOW THAT SENATOR
BATES HAS A LOT OF WORK AHEAD
THIS IS CAN. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
IT COULD. CONTINUE TO WORK IN
PROGRESS AND SO I KNOW THAT.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET TO SOME-
COMPROMISE HERE SOON SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO. ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR THE A ROBUST DEBATE. THANK
YOU TO THE OPPOSITION FOR
LAYING OUT I THINK THE PAST.
ALL THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AS WE GO FORWARD I AM NOT. A
WHOLLY TOTALLY COMMITTED. TO
CONTINUING MY WORK WITH THE ODD
TO GROUPS AND HOPE THEY BECOME
CONGRUENT. AND FIND A CONSENSUS
SOLUTION BUT I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THINGS. WE
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL ON THIS ISSUE I WANT
YOU TO KNOW IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THE ORIGINAL I MEANT THAT.
STILL EXISTS THE ANOTHER
HIGHWAYS CODE WAS SET. UP
THROUGH A STATE PROCESS
CALTRANS WAS THE LEAD. ON THE
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY TRAFFIC
RELIEF EFFORT THAT WAS
TERMINATED. WITH THE SELECTION
OF TERMINATING IT ALSO PARKWAY.
IN THE MARCH DECISION. FINALLY
UP ON THE SAN CLEMENTE HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO. THE BUILDING OF
THE TOLL ROADS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. A TOTAL OF FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST.
SEVERAL YEARS WHICH SHOT
EXCEEDS MOST A- OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ANY OF THE
CITIES. SO THEY HAVE BEEN A
PARTNER. IN THE- CONSTRUCTION
OF ARTERIALS AND CERTAINLY
THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO BE ON.
THIS HELPS OUR ROUTE SEVENTY
FOUR IS IT. ON A PROCEEDS FROM-
NORTH SAN DIEGO ON THE NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY TO ALSO PARKWAY.
SO IT'S BEEN FUN FOR. WE START
YOU KNOW I THINK. A OUR NAY.
AND MY- HERE. AND I THINK WE
ALL OF THAT A TO BRING A
COMMUNITY TOGETHER THAT'S WHY
I'VE TAKEN. ON A IN A NEW ORDER
IN FOR THAT AMOUNT OF TIME%
SINCE LAST AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY. TO ENGAGE ON THIS ISSUE
AND IT IS ONLY BECAUSE I
REINTRODUCED A BILL. THAT WE'VE
BEGUN TO TALK SO. PLEASE GIVE
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP THAT
GOING AND I WANT TO KNOW ALL OF
THE FOLKS THAT ARE SPOKE. TODAY
HAVE BEEN GOOD FRIENDS OF MINE
SO WE MAINTAIN OUR FRIENDSHIP.
WEJUST HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DISAGREEMENT OF STRONG
DISAGREEMENT. IN SOME OF THE
AREAS LAW ON THE BILL FINALLY
ON- ON OF. THE WEAPON. ISSUES I
WANT YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT PRECLUDE. THE
REGION MOVING FORWARD WITH
TRANSPORTATION CONGESTION
RELIEF ALTERNATIVES THERE'S
WIDE SUPPORT FOR THOSE. ARE THE
EXTENSION OF LOS ANGELES
PARKWAY THE WIDENING OF STATE
ROUTE SEVENTY FOUR. IN THE
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY INTERSTATE
FIVE HOV LANE. EXTENSION
PROJECT WHICH WILL RELIEVE
TRAFFIC IN THAT WHOLE REGION.
SOUTH IMPORTANTLY AND MAYBE
MORE SO- THE BILL DOES NOT
PRECLUDE THE COLLECTION OF
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES. THAT
TCA WILL NEED TO MEET ITS
FISCAL OBLIGATION TO NOT ONLY
THOSE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
BUT TO THEIR COMMITMENT TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL MEDICATION. THAT
WILL FOLLOW ARE. AN EXTENSION
UP TO FORTY ONE FOR THE
ARTERIALS IN THAT SAME REGION.
I HAD A LONG DISCUSSION WITH
DOWN SILVER WE WORK TOGETHER
FOR. EIGHT YEARS. ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
PROGRAM. TOGETHER WE WERE ABLE
TO SET ASIDE ELEVEN HUNDRED
ACRES. OF FREED FROM
DEVELOPMENT. IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MR SILVER.
BY HE THOUGHT THE EXTENSION OF
THE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL. MIGHT
BE OF A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. BUT LOT MORE
DISCUSSION NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE
SO. I WITHOUT I STRONGLY
ELSEWHERE AND I VOTE AND GIVE
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
MY EFFORTS. AND I HOPE TO BRING
BACK TO YOU. AS SOMETHING ON
THAT IS A HUGE SOLUTION AND
PERHAPS. WE CAN- TABLE TO
BILLS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES. AND WITH THAT DO
WE. HAVE A MOTION ON SB SEVEN
SIXTY. MOST BY SENATOR WILK.
ALRIGHT MR CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTS FIVE DOLLARS HI EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT FIVE HELEN HI HELEN
HI ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA HI
BAKER RIGHT BAKER HI CORTESE.
CORTESE I DOLLY- I DOT. DODD HI
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI BELINDA'S.
HI LINDA'S AYE MIN. BEEN NO
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER NOT ONLY.
NUMBER MICHALSKI. WILK HI WILK
HI. THIRTEEN ONE. THIRTY ONE
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES- ALRIGHT
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE THROUGH THE
BILLS AND FILE ORDER I THINK WE
HAVE ONE ABSENT MEMBER THAT
NEEDS TO ADD ON A SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SO WE'LL START WITH S.
B. WHAT WE HAVE HERE SB TWO
THIRTY WHEN HE WAS HERE FOR SO
SB THREE SEVENTY TWO. I'M A-
MENTOR WE STILL HAVE- ABSENT
MEMBERS ON- TWO THIRTY ONE. OH
I'M SORRY OKAY SB TWO THIRTY
ONE MISTER CONSULTANT. THE MOST
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR OUR
EYES. LOOK HI WILK HI. FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTY FIVE. SEVENTY TWO
SEVENTEEN ZERO OF THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU. NEXT
BILL WE HAVE ON THE CALL IS SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
LEYVA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSING BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
DOLLARS. FIVE I DOLLARS HI WELL
I'M SORRY THIS IS SENATOR DOLLY
NOT VOTING NINE NINE THANK YOU
SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN ZERO THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD NEXT WE HAVE
SB THREE EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MCGUIRE. I REQUIRE HI SKINNER.
WILK HI WILK HI. SIXTEEN ZERO
SIXTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
NEXT SB FOUR EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR MELINDA IS. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
THE CHAIR IS NO THE VICE CHAIR
IS HI. ALLEN ARCHULETA. BAKER
MCGUIRE. MEN RUBIO. SKINNER
NUMBER. WILK HI WELCOME I. SIX
THREE SIX THREE CONSIDER ALL
RIGHT IN THIS BILL DOES NOT
MOVE FORWARD. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE
HAVE IS SB FIVE FIVE ONE BY
SENATOR STERN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR R.
HI. ELLEN AND ELLEN HI. BAKER
HI BAKER HI WHAT MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ NO MELENDEZ NO.
SKINNER SKINNER HI WHAT COUNTY.
FOURTEEN TO FOURTEEN TO THE
BILL IS OUT OF NEXT SB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHERUSCI THE VICE CHAIRS NOT
VOTED. BATES ALLEN HI ELLEN I.
MCGUIRE WHERE HI MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ NO SKINNER SKINNER HI
WILK NO WILK NO. THIRTEEN THREE
THIRTEEN THREE THE BILL IS OUT
NEXT SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR WESSEL. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR R. HI.
ALAN ALL RIGHT ELLEN HI WHERE
MCGUIRE HI. WILK HI WILK HI.
SEVENTEEN ZERO SEVENTEEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT NEXT SB SIX SIX
FORTY THREE BY ARCHULETA. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR ARE HIGH. ALLEN
ALL RIGHT ELLEN HI WHERE
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER THIS I'M
BURKE HI NUMBER HI WILK HI WILK
I. SIXTEEN ZERO THANK YOU THE
BILL IS OUT NEXT SB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR DORADO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIRS I THE VICE DOES NOT
BODE. BATES. HELEN HI HELEN HI
BAKER HI BAKER HI DOLLY NOPE
DALY NO WHERE. MCGUIRE AYE
BELINDA'S BLOOD IS NOW. NUMBER
WELL. TWELVE TO TWELVE TO THE
BILL IS OUT. NEXT SB SEVEN TWO
SIX GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR R. HI
ALAN HI ALAN HI BAKER HI BAKER
HI. DOLLY WHERE FIRE HI LINDA
SNOW MELENDEZ NOW SKINNER. WHAT
COUNTY. THIRTEEN ONE I WAS OUT
LAST BILL SB SEVEN SIXTY BATES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR R. HI. SKINNER
UMBERG WHITE HOUSE SO THAT AT
THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE THE BILL
IS OUT IN THE ABSENT CALENDAR
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR LET'S
GO AHEAD AND MOVE THROUGH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE TO
CONSENT CALENDARS THE FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THAT C. R.
TWENTY SIX AND CASSIE ARE
TWENTY SEVEN THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR R. HI. ALAN HI ELLEN
FIVE. DOT RUBIO. NUMBER HI WITH
A COMPELLING. THIRD RUBIO I.
THE. FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO
ON THE FIRST PART OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IT IS APPROVED
THE NEXT ONE THE SECOND
CONCERT- THE SECOND CONSENT
CALENDAR. IT IS SB SIXTY SIX SB
SEVENTY NINE SB FIVE SEVENTY SB
SIX TO NINE S. B. EIGHT ONE
FOUR AND S. C. R. TWENTY EIGHT
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR R.
HI. ALAN DOT. RUBIO. RUBIO HI
NUMBER. HELEN I. FIFTEEN ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO SUPPOSED CONSENT
CALENDARS HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED.